this is Jocko podcast number 364 with
Dave Burke and me Dr willink good
evening Dave good evening
The misties Who volunteered were among
the most talented hard-working
courageous group of men I have ever
encountered
to a man they were remarkable Pilots
they worked long hours days on end to
get the program started
during the early missions we were
consumed with establishing procedures
deciding on tactics constructing our
Maps testing varied equipment and
aircraft configurations and learning the
area
it was really hunt and Peck trial by
fire
we decided on three cycle missions using
two in-flight refuelings
we were looking for road traffic storage
areas and Sams which were beginning to
move into the lower parts of the pack
those early Misty missions were really
hairy as we experimented with how to
survive in a dense AAA environment while
marking targets and directing strikes
though facking was not a New Concept the
U.S Air Force had employed facts since
World War II
fast-facking was new and we were truly
plowing new ground
we had to learn to operate and survive
in a very dense threat environment while
operating for extended periods at low
altitude dicey stuff
our loss rate during the first six
months
was 42 percent
a steep expensive and tragic learning
curve
I cannot emphasize too strongly the
courage of the first group of men who
raised their hands
they were going where no Jet Pilot had
ever been before to do dangerous things
no one had ever done
and that right there is an excerpt from
a book a book called
Misty
which is the book is made up of a bunch
of first-person accounts of Misty pilots
in Vietnam and that particular account
was from a man named Bud day who is the
founder
and the first commanding officer of the
Misty Squadron
which he commanded for about two months
before he was shot down
he was captured by the Communists
he actually escaped his initial
captivity but he was shot and recaptured
and then he was sent to the Hanoi Hilton
where he spent five years and seven
months as a pow
upon his release he was awarded the
Medal of Honor for his personal bravery
and his leadership
in the face of extreme enemy pressure
but even while he was in captivity
the rest of the Squadron the Misty
Pilots they continued on
they flew the
F-100 Super saber which is known as the
Hun
there were
157 Pilots that served as Misty fast
facts and facts stands for a Ford air
controller they were around from 1967 to
1970.
and as Forward Air controllers that
meant they did that from the sky
they were marking targets and directing
other aircraft to take out those targets
and it was a very dangerous job
especially because
the Misty Pilots did a bulk of their
flying in North Vietnam where they were
exposed to the most intense of the enemy
air defenses
and of those 157 Pilots
34 were shot down two were shot down
twice
23 were recovered
four were captured by the enemy
seven
were killed in action
but
they were able to accomplish their
mission they were able to get bombs on
target destroy critical enemy nodes
and deliver close air support to troops
on the ground
and it's an honor to have one of those
Pilots
with us here tonight to discuss his
experiences and his lessons learned his
name is Dick Rutan
he served 20 years in the Air Force
and in addition to his combat experience
he was a test pilot a record-setting
pilot he piloted the first plane around
the world with no stopping and no
refueling he's also an author
he wrote a book called Voyager and
another book
called the next five minutes
and it's an honor like I said to have
him here tonight Dick Rutan dick thank
you so much for joining us well it's
great to be here
I'm a great fan it's uh
man when you think about this new
mission that you guys picked up and
what it's like to learn when you're
learning curve is you're learning in
combat that's a that's a rough thing to
get into
a rough way to try and figure things out
well trial by fire that's why it's
called the
initially it was called the Voyager or
the
the Misty experience the the Misty
experiment there we go anyway there's a
there's a thing on PBS that's very
popular now about that that was made up
so about the Misty Pilots well it's
called Misty the Misty ex the Misty
experiment uh it's on PBS oh well I
haven't seen that one yet but I'll
definitely check that one out because
it's
anytime you're exploring new ground like
that and you're doing in a combat
situation that's that's a scary thing to
do and you guys were definitely doing it
um
so let's before we get into that let's
let's start at the beginning and about
kind of where you came from in the
beginning and I'm going to go to your so
your book you've written two books this
one's called the next five minutes
embracing The Impossible
and you say in this book my father Dr
George a Rutan always said he had an
inkling that my life would involve
Adventure even as a baby in diapers I
was exploring our farm in Rural Oregon
I wanted to see and touch and explore it
all looking back I realized that our
parents gave their children the precious
gift of freedom to explore the world and
experience life they never held us back
from doing anything even if
some fought it risky or dangerous my dad
lovingly called pop was a product of the
Great Depression and a World War II Navy
veteran
he took advantage of his VA benefits and
put himself through dental school then
moved his family to Dinuba am I saying
that right that's right Dinuba Dinuba a
small agricultural Heartland town 35
miles Southeast of Fresno California it
was the perfect place to grow up to fly
Cessnas and Piper Cubs to ride
motorcycles and to throw toilet paper
out of an airplane over the high school
during a Friday night football game
while riding my BSA Motorcycle I was
often chased out of town by local cops
but usually found a way to ditch them by
riding through neighborhood Vineyards
I knew they couldn't catch me although
many tried I enjoyed the thrill of this
count mask count cat and mouse game even
when the officers would caution my
parents about my unruliness so there's a
little glimpse into your uh into your
childhood sounds like you were a handful
now it's great Dynamo was an absolute
fantastic place to grow up they had the
freedom a lot of agriculture
and uh
that's when we learn how to fly little
airplanes and would be buzzing and
throwing toilet paper out like they said
so what what did your dad do in the Navy
uh dad got in at the at the very end
of the of the uh of the war in fact uh
he should have been exempt
and he called up and there was a mistake
someplace and they uh
uh they gave him a draft notice he says
hey I'm married and I have a family and
I should be exempt and they thought well
yeah you're right but he says you know
something my country is at War and God
damn it I'm going to go and he did and
so what do you do in the Navy
uh he was I think he was a corpsman
there and uh Farragut
uh in fact that's up where we live right
now in Coeur d'Alene Idaho
by Lake Ponderay and there's a big huge
Naval Base up there and uh
uh that's where he spent the end of the
war he never made it into uh
into a ship or into combat or anything
and then he then he uses GI bill to pay
for dental school it became a dentist
that's right like many of those vets
they took advantage of that and I think
it was a probably one of the best
investments our country ever made
yeah and then you know you met you've
already talked to me we're we're like
two paragraphs into the beginning of the
book and you're already talking about
flying Cessnas what was your first
experience in a plane
well uh
uh it was right after World War II it
was just a little kid I can't remember
exactly what it was but my mother
oh and dad was going through dental
school we didn't have any money and for
some reason mom
uh took me out to a place called flabob
they're in Riverside it's a little grass
field
and she bought an airplane ride for this
little kid
and to this day I can remember almost
every detail of that experience
we went out there and we're going to fly
and it was a pretty neat thing but and
at that time that airport was just a
grass field someplace
and it was in a piper it's a J5 Piper
Cub in the back seat was a little wider
and then that means that two people
could sit there okay well they put Mom
and I in the back and when I sat out I
couldn't see out you know the windows
were too high and I said there's no fine
way that I'm going to sit in this hole
in this experience so I stood up and and
grabbed onto the pilot seat
and you know it was an old airplane and
and I can still remember
the stuffing and I can still remember
what it smelled like
and I remember that the tires had no
tread
and somebody came out and hand propped
the airplane and got it going
uh and we accelerated the Big Thrill
of lifting off and seeing an entire new
world that I had never experienced even
existed
and for that 15 minutes that we flew
over Riverside and I still remember the
the famous mission in
and had no idea that later on that I was
going to be honored with a set of wings
in the Flyers wall
but anyway I looked down and it was so
amazing
and uh and it would what I saw that day
would change my life forever
uh mom would say her two sons
they had aviation fuel instead of blood
and they were not issued birth
certificates they were issued
fly plants
and so it from that moment on it was in
a an extreme I guess abnormal
Fascination for Aviation and
unfortunately maybe at the expense of a
more rounded character development and I
knew a lot about airplanes
everything
as they flew over you could identify
which one they were
and I knew what kind of motor engines
they had and so forth
but the other things to make a rounded
experience for growing up I knew
absolutely Jack Squad about anything
so as you're growing up so you
definitely want to be a pilot oh
absolutely did you want to be a military
pilot
uh yes uh to go back a little to go back
a little bit more
uh I grew up in the dawn of the victory
of World War II and this time I became
fascinated with Aviation and then and I
was really fascinated about combat
and I found it very intriguing
and as I learned more about those guys
that flew out of the Eighth Air Force in
East Anglia in England
and those long missions and b-17s and
b-24s
and I learned about the loss rates
you know one group had come back and 600
beds would be empty
who are these people that did that
when three-fourths of them were
casualties
and I thought
oh in the hell
you know it's one thing to go and do
that once but if you're the only one
that comes back from your whole Squadron
with Wounded on board how and the love
of whatever do you get back in another
airplane and do that again
I was fascinated who the hell are these
people
and then you had to ask the question
again you know I kind of wanted to be a
warrior
I always thought it was the ultimate in
human competition is where the Pinnacle
is where each other would compete
for the Ultimate Prize and that's your
life
and uh oh it's it's fascinating how can
I could I do something like that and I
had to find out one way or another
I had a learning experience a learning
problem
it was diagnosed just a few years ago
actually when I was trying to write this
book and I was telling people how I read
and how I process sometimes but it was a
dislikely whatever that is dyslexic
and I always had a hard time in school
uh
but uh that fascinating that the
fascination for whatever the Warrior's
life was I don't know I had to find out
for myself
now every young Warrior grows up and
pretty soon he's a warrior and the time
goes by and he becomes the age to be a
warrior okay I'm a young guy and I'm I'm
in the I'm in the thing right now this
is Warrior and then you walk outside and
look around and think well what war am I
going to fight this is a small window of
opportunity actually and I looked around
frick it was Vietnam
but I still had to find out and that was
something that was kind of known in my
in my back uh all that time I couldn't
wait to do that I had to find out if
Little Dicky Rutan can do that
and uh
you know our parents gave us some really
important things one of them is freedom
there's a world out there I gave you
life
you can make of it what you want
and I remember uh well my mom would take
it to air shows
and this was in Merced California and I
was a little kid
and I never forget that I was walking up
there and there was an rf-84 a
reconnaissance f-84 uh jet
smell like a jet kerosene
and I remember looking in the windows
the camera windows and they had scantily
clad females in there and I thought wow
this is really cool
and then I saw that pilot standing there
and he looked really cool man they had
his G suit on his flight suit on this
had his wings and he was a pilot man and
he was a flyer he could go and fly that
airplane
and I stood there and looked up at him
and my mother
what she said right then was really
important kind of a turning place in my
life
and my mom look at looked at me and she
says dick would you like to do that I
says oh God would I ever but then I said
something to the fact that I don't think
that I could ever achieve that
and she grabbed me by the neck or the
nap and she said in no uncertain terms
looked at me and she says if you want to
do that you can and don't you ever say
that you can't do something like that
and that was the the motivation
uh like she says you can do if you can
dream it you can do it and the only way
to fail is if you quit
and to achieve all those things that you
dream about all you have to do is manage
the motivation
and so on that day and that Castle Air
Force Base in front of that f-84
she instilled the fact that
I could really do that
now is he able to take that focus and
get it towards your grades in school
because according to your book no I
always had problems in school and you
just and that was driven somewhat by
your dyslexia it was by dyslexia nobody
could uh nobody could identify it or
nobody could evaluate what the hell was
Bert was Dicky having a problem in
school in fact my dad
uh right after grade school right after
high school he sent me down to a
university I think in Southern
California for an aptitude test hey it's
just you know who is this kid is he
what's his aptitude is is he a college
type and whatever
and I went down and took the test and
Pop came back and says
uh
it scored very very low and
well like in English as an example
communication skills but I I was very
extremely high mechanical
uh very high mechanical aptitude
and so then I wasn't going to be a
college guy obviously
and not to jump ahead too much but I
went in the Air Force right out of high
school
and as I was going through
advancement and so forth to be a
lieutenant colonel I had to have a
college degree so in that time they had
a bootstrap program
we talk about motivation again the
bootstrap program so here I am I'm going
to be a lieutenant colonel I got about
18 years in the service
and they sent me off to uh Clinton Texas
uh the American Technological University
and for about a semester or whatever it
was three or four or five months
and I went out there by myself and then
a little apartment now here this older
guy you know he's been to Vietnam and
we've been through the the Cold War and
setting nuclear alert and stuff and I'm
looking around at all these kids out
here drinking and raising hell and
chasing girls
and I wasn't doing any of that like and
it dawned on me and he says hey uh
you know you did have problems with this
and I thought this is college you know
geez that's always scared of college
I wonder how I'll do
and then I thought what the motivation
was I got a family and two kids I need
to get promoted and if I don't I'm going
to give up retirement and all those
other benefits and stuff and the
humility of coming back and failing this
thing
and so I figured out a way
I get a briefcase and I put a tape
recorder in it and I sat down in that
seat right in front of that professor
and I didn't have anything else I wasn't
drinking and I wasn't chasing girls or
anything so every every word that he had
I wrote uh notes you know detailed notes
of this thing
and here this dyslexic kid that had a
problem in any kind of academic
situation
he graduated
with the the BS agree
on the dangerous and a 4-0 average
holy Manhattan and it's just it's just
the motivation so you can accomplish
anything if you can all you have to do
is manage the motivation if you keep
yourself motivated or motivate those
around you
uh as an example of the world flight
project
I kept thinking and we had some horrible
times you know challenges the five and a
half years with no money having to build
this big huge airplane ourselves by hand
uh
uh the flight test dangers as hell I
don't know how I ever survived that
thing this frail little airplane that
was going to go 29 000 miles
wow
and and when things were falling apart I
want to give up
about motivation again I would go out in
a special place and this little
crummy little airport Mojave abandoned
semi-abandoned military field in in
Mojave California in the high desert
next to Edwards Air Force Base
and I have a special place that I would
sit down in the hangar
by the hanger look in the ramp and
looking out over the desert
and
and it's some you know just
insurmountable problem difficulties
and I closed my eyes and I would try to
imagine what it would feel like to land
at Edwards Air Force Base having
accomplished aviation's last milestone
and I closed my eyes and let that
feeling permeate through my psychic and
I'd realize
this is the last you know the last
milestone in aviation it's an
unrefutable world flight
and I think and out loud after thinking
about that and let it settle into my
psychic and thought
you know I'd feel pretty good
I'd feel pretty good and for five and a
half years when I was really down and
dejected I saw it out there and closed
my eyes and try to visualize that
and then that was managed managed the
motivation
uh and I found that that's really a key
thing and I try to tell people about
that if you can dream it you can do it
but just manage the motivation and you
can accomplish anything
now as you're growing up you also you
got your brother Bert right right
another bird and it sounds like you two
are thick as thieves in everything that
you're doing right well not really we're
five years apart so therefore we were
never in the same school at the same
time I was gone uh
you know went to a high school and and
being five years apart I was gone a year
and before he even started
so we weren't really all that close I
guess in some ways you know I guess it
seems like you caught you became close
later well yeah we were brothers uh he
was you know I was a guy that was riding
motorcycles and getting chased by the
cops and stuff and buzzing around Friday
night high school games and being the
the long-haired uh Elvis Presley haircut
with dirty Levi's hanging on the last
the last hair on my ass and so forth and
you know he was the one that was more
studious I think that
the education thing
uh the two brothers uh he got a lot of
you got a lot of what I needed to go to
school of course I took away from him
some of the the mechanical part of it
and so forth and that's why so you're
growing up in the 50s because you're
born in what 30 38 38 right so you're
growing up in the 50s this is and in
California in the 50s Elvis motorcycles
Levi's jeans like you had the whole
thing going on right out of a movie
American Graffiti that's it if you
remember that movie yeah I mean I
thought that they had done American
Graffiti in my little town because all
those characters I knew every one of
them I went to school with them
now you also mentioned the book that you
were scared of heights
yes what was that all about
uh
well uh a phobia
well I call it it's Edge phobia I think
I was really really and my brother and I
both have Ed's phobia if you get I
couldn't write in glass elevators
or I couldn't look off a tall building
or look over a cliff
and I didn't realize
you know this later on during the
Voyager project
is that uh I always thought that phobias
were just [__] things you know so what
you're what are you scared of height not
Heights but you're scared of of
what spiders or scared of being in a
tight place
uh and I just thought that was that was
a [__] thing
but it was uh but the fear of heights it
it became a debilitating phobia
that I go over next to a cliff or
something
and become cold and clammy uncontrolled
shaking extreme heart rates
the inability to in the Ragged edge of
being panicked
and so I've had that all my life I guess
I just how do you cure to that stay the
hell away from
high places don't look off big Cliffs
and stuff and I thought everybody had
that you know you're supposed to be
afraid of being high for crying out loud
so I just thought that was normal
until uh
that particular thing happened
during the stress of our Voyager project
that there was a lot of stress mental
stress and stuff for that you know no
money
trying to do it with volunteers people
volunteers would not show up they'd only
do half of it and it was very stressful
especially with no money
and the thing is to hell with it we're
going to do it anyway it just it's a
neat thing
so I took up and took off in my Long
Easy that I built
one of the first models that my brother
designed called Long Easy
and I took off one day and I did the
first turn out of traffic
and it hit me
uh that debilitating phobia happened to
me in Flight I never had any problem in
Flight just looking over the edge of a
cliff and it hit me it hit me so bad
uh cold and clammy and heart race
inability to do almost anything
and it skidded the airplane around and
finally damn near crashed on the runway
trying to get back
and taxied in and then sitting there by
myself and the heart rate would slow
down I could kind of relax a little bit
and then I thought holy crap dick you're
right in the middle of the Voyager
project this is your project you're
going to be the commander you're going
to be the guy you're going to be the guy
that lands at Edwards Air Force Base and
taxied up for the whole world having
accomplished this
great
milestone achievement
and I can't fly I'm screwed what the
hell am I going to do
I knew right away that I could never
tell anybody about that you know who in
the hell would ever fly with me again
and rightfully so I wouldn't blame him I
said this guy for some unknown reason
could have a debilitating phobia I mean
that's a grounding thing
and it so happened that it was in Las
Vegas
it was in the Hilton Hotel
and it was sitting at the bar that some
real strange things happened fortuitous
what happened at the bars in Vegas well
it was in a bar but that wasn't the
point I remember for some reason I I sat
down next to some guy
and we stock up a conversation and I
found out that he ran he runs a clinic
for fear of flight
you know people have that passengers and
people come in and uh they go through a
program about trying to overcome fear or
flight I said what
boy
I need to know about this
and so as it turned out he was very
forthcoming and I would ask questions
you know the details
of the program and how you do that what
is
I mean how do you cure people of this
thing for crying out loud and he was
very forthcoming and boy old dick he was
taking detailed memory notes of
everything that happened then I realized
dick you can never tell anybody about
that
in fact I don't think anybody ever knew
until they read my book
uh
anyway and I did it it was a self it was
a self-help a self-cure thing it was
really incredible and at the end of
myself
my self-taught clinic I have no fear of
flights no fear of heights any place
I thought wait a minute
you're supposed to have a little bit of
fear because if you fall you could get
hurt really bad
what was the Crux of getting through
that well uh because just so for context
for everybody that doesn't know the
whole story I mean when you're working
on the Voyager flight when you had this
so you've been you've been scared of
heights your whole life but you'd also
been a pilot your whole life at this
point you'd flown in Vietnam you'd
parachute you've done a bunch of things
that had to do with Heights but then for
some reason
in the middle of this effort to go and
fly around the world in the Voyager
aircraft
you're getting another little aircraft
which by the way I look at your your
brother's little aircrafts that he build
and they're like little one-seaters they
look like you could they look like a
little model airplane that I used to
build right so maybe that's what you
were scared of but you get up on this
flight and all of a sudden you get this
this hype Panic yeah see uh when this
thing the Panic happened I've already
been through my civilian thing and I was
a flight instructor and I went in the
Air Force and went through pilot
training with combat uh set nuclear
alert all those things have already been
done before I finally did my 20 years
and one microsecond by the way
and we could talk about what was going
on then
uh so anyway I got out at 20 years in a
microsecond and then enjoying my brother
and then we did the round the world
thing so I had I had flown a lot
and none of that phobia or scareness or
anything ever manifests itself in Flight
you know I could you know heroin fighter
pilot for crying out loud we do air
shows
and I just felt right at home and there
was never any situation until that one
particular thing under a lot of stress
that it it finally crawled out of my
psyche and hit me really bad and I had
to cure myself of it so what did you do
to cure yourself though
well
um first of all you have to get all the
symptoms going I mean real quick and so
I was in uh you know there's some of
these hotels that that have a matrix an
Atrium inside and you come out of your
room and you're looking inside the hotel
and they're you know you look over the
edge and it's really a long ways down
there
and you go up to the edge and you get
all the symptoms going
all of them
and it took all the willpower I could to
almost drag myself grab the edge and
pull myself up and look at it and the
more that I look down the more the more
this phobia would just explode into my
psychic heart rate breath skin cold and
clammy and uncontrolled shaking
and the first thing you do with this you
get all the symptoms going
and then you identify one part of your
body and you concentrate on it totally
on that particular thing
and I chose my right elbow
because it was shaking
and I concentrate as much as I can and I
finally that there may be no kidding
after 20 minutes I could get that one
elbow to stop to to stop shaking
and I says oh that's really cool I says
well I'm going to try the Ella elbows as
soon as I would go to work on the other
elbow the first one would start again
they didn't have to go back and do that
but that was it was a procedure that you
would get one
you would slow down one arm and then you
were able to to control it
boy you went to the other arm
or the right leg or the right calf or
one part of it and so you go through
this procedure you drag yourself up
there and and this phobia would just
explode on you everything was gone then
you go down right elbow left elbow right
knee left knee until you got them all
calm and if you concentrate on it you
can keep them quiet but soon as you
would try to do something else boom
they'd explode again but what I'm
getting at is
as you go through this procedure
uh
and you can can finally uh
start to control everything and then
your skin doesn't cold and clammy
anymore and you feel relaxed but the
problem was I can control my breathing
I can decide when to take a breath and
not
but what do you do about this damn thing
in my chest it's going like mad really
high really high on heart rates
and then if it's a thing called
biofeedback
and they talk about how you go with
biofeedback to be able to control your
heart rate
and then pretty soon
I could go up and if it if the tens
would happen I'd go right over the left
elbow left and just calm everything down
and then eventually
eventually I had no symptoms whatsoever
not even a normal fear of heights on the
edge
got it solved and then
but but then you think hey there's this
thing back in the corner of Dick's
psychic someplace this Gremlin could
crawl out again
that's why I could never tell anybody
about that got to keep that one quiet
especially the insurance people
especially the insurance or the FAA and
my medical because I knew that that was
a grounding a big time grounding item
for the FAA
um
so that let's get back I want to get
back to uh sort of how you got into
flying in the first place I'm gonna go
back to the book here and again look the
book is awesome so many so many details
inside the book just go get the book I'm
going to read some highlights from it
well but there's plenty more highlights
that we're not going to read but just to
kind of talk through the story a little
bit you say this throughout my childhood
I struggled with academics a struggle
that was almost debilitating regardless
of how hard I might try it seemed I was
doomed for failure I was held back a
year in elementary school but nothing
improved by the time I reached High
School pop decided to have a battery of
tests run to help me clarify my
strengths and weaknesses it was
determined I had exceptional High
Mechanical Aptitude but skills in other
areas suggested I was not College
material
decades decades later would pass before
it was discovered I suffered from
undiagnosed dyslexia
what I did know was I had a gift and a
passion for flying and aspired to make
my mark doing something in that field
fresh out of high school I could hardly
wait for the opportunity to fly high in
the stratosphere and make those white
Vapor contrails so I signed up for the
United States Air Force Aviation Cadet
program after taking all the tests and
going through the rigorous physical and
written exams I was told I was qualified
I was not qualified to be a pilot even
though I was already a civilian
commercial pilot but they had a special
program for me I could become a
navigator
I couldn't believe it I was fully
physically qualified I had fighter
pilots eyes but did not score the best
in academics I suspect that I'd that
that had everything to do with their
decision to reject my application for
pilot training I complained to my Air
Force Recruiting Sergeant he told me all
I had to do was when I got to pre-flight
at Lackland Air Force Base and San
Antonio was telling them about my
civilian pilot status and they would
change me right over to Pilot training
that was the first that was one of the
first lies told to me in my new way of
life away from home it all seemed so
simple and I signed the dotted line
this is the first time I'd ever been
away from my mom my family and the
safety of my sheltered life I stepped
off the bus in my low hanging Levi's and
long greased up Elvis haircut I soon
discovered I would lose my cool hair and
during the next two weeks would only be
allowed to mutter yes sir or no sir this
once [__] hot civilian pilot was now off
to nav school it nearly broke my heart
along with my spirit the cadets assigned
a pilot training were issued brand new
shiny helmets while I was issued three
large books of celestial site reduction
tables
so that's your introduction you get you
get uh this assignment to be a navigator
you go to nav class you end up as a
backseater as a Rio a radar intercept
officer
you get stationed in Oregon
from Oregon uh you get stationed up in
Iceland
and then when you get to Iceland you you
apply for pilot training again and you
get accepted
um and when you get accepted for that
you get assigned to an Air transport
Squadron uh which is flying in and out
of Vietnam which now the Vietnam war is
kind of getting
kind of getting started or starting to
escalate I should say well yeah what
happened
uh
you know I had no interest in navigating
big cargo airplanes back and forth so
then that went into the fighters you
know I was flying Fighters but in the
back seat as a radar intercept officer
and then I applied for pilot training
for some reason if I fly in the back
seat long enough according to the Air
Force I got a lot smarter
so then I was smart enough that I could
go to Pilot train
so while I was waiting for to go to
Pilot train and I was assigned to uh
c-124's cargo big old
they call it a big old shaky
and while I was waiting to go to Pilot
training
uh I was actually flying as a navigator
now and this big huge cargo airplane
this is in uh you know right in the
middle of Vietnam War back and forth to
Saigon
and as it turned out
those hours that I spent at 8 000 feet
in a c124 waiting to go to Pilot
training gave me some incredible
understanding of what I was going to
face later on in life to fly this
Voyager around the world
and as it turned out having had that nav
experience
that may have been that may have been
critical to the success of the Flight
Around the World in the Voyager
so I don't know maybe maybe Faye goes
around and it comes back around again
who can tell uh
[Music]
so but you do end up finally like you
said you got a lot smarter as you as you
flew around in the back of the airplanes
you got a lot smarter you got accepted
for pilot trading and you say this in
the book before I knew it pilot training
67d was ready to begin and my time as a
navigator came to an end I was off off
to Laughlin Air Force Base in Del Rio
Texas right on the Rio Grande River West
of San Antonio although I didn't
appreciate it at the time my experience
as a navigator over vast stretches of
open ocean and training with radar would
prove to be a vital factor in the
successful completion of voyager's
flight years later because of my
academic challenges I knew how I had to
work clever work hard and maintain my
motivation to be successful in Pilot
training I would sneak a tape recorder
into class by concealing into my
briefcase I made it a point to sit front
center row so I could capture every word
of each lecture with the help of these
taped lectures I arduously wrote
impeccable notes to study from and aced
every test
I graduated number one in my pilot
training class granted I had a huge head
start with more flying time log than
many of the instructors but I never told
anyone I was a civilian pilot I was a
civilian instructor pilot I let them
believe I was just that good
upon graduation I was awarded my dream
the F-100 Super Saver affectionately
known as the Hun
out of 360 graduates there were only two
f-100s offered with that I was off to
real life and death combat in Vietnam
so you kept it a secret that you were a
civilian but like how many hours did you
have well see I wanted to go to the Air
Force pilot attorney and I can go back
to that day that I stood there and at
March Air Force Base looking up at that
fighter pilot you know he was a god from
a different place and here after all
those the the interim years I was going
to be able to do that now I always made
a joke
that I always thought if you want to be
a real Air Force fighter pilot you had
to go to Luke Air Force Base and you had
to
he had a train in the hunt he was a
difficult airplane to fly it had some
really
strange things about the airplane
that that was more of a challenge
I says if you want to be a real fighter
pilot you got to go through Luke Gunnery
School in the F-100
and so I talked about that during my
pilot training days you know I was
bragging I said I'm going to get an
F-100 and I said [__] routine I says
they haven't given a undergraduate pilot
training right out of training to go
directly to fly this
really weird airplane
I said that's all right this is uh it's
all I have to have is one
because I'm going to graduate out of 365
pilots in five different bases that was
number one
well you talk about a heads up I had to
bite my bite my tongue a lot because I
wasn't you know I was a civilian flight
instructor but I had been wanting to go
to Pilot training all my life I wanted
to go to that training
and and I didn't want anybody giving any
shortcuts or bragging about hey I'm
already a pilot and the old old hammage
is it says that's a lollipop
that I've been wanting to lick for a
long time and I want to look and I want
to lick every darn bit of that
now it came to the point when you
graduate the class standings
and this is kind of more or less a
metaphor but they have all the
assignments written on the on the
Blackboard scene and there's a curtain
and they come up and they say okay who's
number one in the class
and they open up the curtain and there's
all the all the assignments
uh
and I looked up there and much to my
shock there was two f-100s
now I've been bragging about everybody
says oh [__] this no there's no way
but it opened up
they were surprised
but the most surprised person in that
whole room
was me I had no idea that it would be
there
and I walked up just like yeah I knew it
all the time yes
squat all the time
and uh of course then went to Gunnery
school and from there on to Vietnam so
when you were coming through as a as a
pilot a civilian pile instructor like
how many hours of flying did you have
well uh this this is a guess I probably
had a couple thousand hours so Dave
Burke how much of an advantage is that
oh go through pilot training when you
have a couple thousand hours worth of
flight well it was a flight Destructor
thing too see I was I sold it on the day
I sold it on the day that it was 16 my
16th birthday
my mom drove me out and I sold it in a
little Cessna 140 and then I
uh
it took me down to the DMV and I did my
driver's test and then I could drive my
mom home for the first time
so I was so I was a pilot before and
then your 17th birthday the day that you
needed to be to be a Private Pilot that
I could carry passengers and so forth
and then at 18 years old it could be a
commercial pilot
and um flight instructor
so Dave what's the assessment you have 2
000 hours worth of pilot time and you're
going through pilot training that's
definitely going to help but in in
Dick's offense that can that can cut
both ways and when I was in Flight
School the kids now nobody nobody hit it
you know you couldn't hide it I think
when I was going through if you had
flight time everybody knew it
some of the best students had experience
but some of the worst students were the
ones that had experience too so I think
you you obviously had to keep that to
yourself and and uh you have to not
reveal your bad habits or your habits
that you have brought as an aviator and
you got to pretend like it's all new so
I haven't provide experience mostly it
helps but it's I saw kids struggle a lot
because they didn't want to learn a new
way of doing it so a few guys that had a
flight time I didn't get through the
program particularly because they were
unwilling to adapt to a new way of doing
it it sounds like you didn't have that
hey Dave you're exactly right because
and it had to be very careful of that
but it wasn't the fact that I was uh I
was going to be
like the civilians do it better or
something
but I was just I noticed that I was just
amazed about how different things were
it's all proceduralized
uh like in military pilot training uh
you you to enter the pattern is exactly
flights there's a bridge you'd have to
overfly and then there was a there was a
how Farmers Pump House on his thing and
then you turned downwind and it was all
proceduralized you know brace talk trim
turn very very regiment it's a very
regimented and it was amazing I thought
you know somebody that farmer goes out
there and tears down that pump house
none of these guys could get back
but it's just the procedure and but
that's that's the way it was but the
thing was that I sat there I remembered
as a as a little kid sitting there in
Dinuba picking grapes or something and
looking up and see those contrails a
single contrail so high that I could not
see what was making them and I looked up
at that thing and never forget I said
damn that's I got it there's nothing
else I got to do I mean the desire to be
at the pointy end of that contrail
it was overwhelming here again the mo
the motivation
and there it was two Savers up for grabs
and you got one of them I got one
um I'm gonna fast forward a little bit
in the book here you say my assignment
to Vietnam is a combat fighter pilot was
typical after completing Advanced
Gunnery school at Luke Air Force Base in
Phoenix Arizona the this newly minted
jet fighter pilot attended Air Force
survival school at Fairchild Air Force
Base in Spokane Washington it was
February dead of winter I would be
stationed in the jungle Tropics but was
being trained to survive and waste deep
snow
on our ride to Vietnam we made a short
stop at Clark Air Force Base in hot and
sticky Philippines where we received
specific jungle survival training this
environment was definitely more
representative of what we would have to
face in the jungles of Vietnam instead
of having to build a shelter in the snow
we learned how to catch kill and eat boa
constrictors
arriving in Vietnam I had to burn bum a
ride from Saigon in a C-130 flying 300
miles north to Phuket where the 35th
tactical Fighter Wing was located in
August of 1967 I was assigned the 416th
Squadron as a newbie fighter pilot to
get checked out in combat
South Vietnam most of the action was air
to ground in support of the troops in
support of the ground troops being a
newbie I was always the tail end Charlie
at the end of the four ship formation
we would check in with the Forward Air
controller a guy in a little Cessna and
he would fire a smoke rocket into the
jungle we would hit his smoke with R4
500 pound Mark 82 bombs and then return
to base I seldom saw any ground Fire
coming my way
so that's kind of your introduction you
get over there you're doing these
missions
[Music]
um
and then this happens you say finally
the day I had been anticipating my
entire life arrived how would I react to
being shot at directly my target this
day was a bunker complex and the goal is
to drop Napalm into the tunnels I flew
at low altitude assumed a shallow dive
angle and snuggled up close to the enemy
tunnels to hit the target as I rolled in
just off to the to the right of my
bunker Target a 50 caliber AAA opened up
firing bright tracers the Tracer scream
was aimed directly at me and they were
close someone down there was trying to
kill me specifically
this is the moment that would define me
as a warrior or as a coward
in 1803 President Jefferson sent Lewis
and Clark on the three-year core of
Discovery to open up the West upon their
return Captain Merriweather Lewis told
the president the greatest acceleration
a man exhilaration a man can feel
is being shot at and missed
as that long stream of trapers tracers
zipped past my canopy my first thought
was not to turn away or hide between my
knees or to cry for my mother
it was exactly the opposite my first
reaction was the audacity of that son of
a [__] to shoot at me
generally the next thing you do will get
you killed resetting the site from the
bombs to guns I rolled hard right and
headed in to destroy that bastard
observing this my flight lead screamed
rutand get the hell out of here there I
argued but sir he shot at me
he repeated Rutan get the hell out of
there and probably saved my foolish
amateur ass
Captain Lewis was right the exhilaration
was overwhelming and extremely addictive
At Last I had found my answer to how
those World War II bomber crews could go
out again and again
I too could do it I was a Combat Warrior
I loved it I welcomed it I needed more
much more
as my combat career progressed I was
described by some as aggressive among
the aggressive
I had not come to Vietnam to drop bombs
on the top of trees
as with most Hot Shot fighter pilots I
came
to kick some ass win and then go home
pretty good introduction to combat
it sure was but then it answered a lot
of questions but it also found it
generated something else
I don't know if I talked about that
about I call the uh
there's an adrenaline gland most people
have
and I call it a combat gland and I think
it's right here on the right side of my
neck someplace
and what happens it it's only active if
somebody shoots at you
and then it gets active and what it
pumps into your psychic into your system
is the most uh well it's extremely
addictive
and euphoric addictive and euphoric and
it's like uh an addiction a drug
addiction well maybe it is a metaphor
again
but you need to have more and more
and then I found out about Misty mm-hmm
about kind of by accident
that that was part of the I think that's
the only mistake I made in the book it's
the 35th Tech fighter one it's actually
a 37th but whatever
but anyway there was this little little
Detachment of the a very small
a very small group of people and a very
highly classified area and doing some
really shut out stuff
and I thought that's what I came here
for
yeah you you write about here about the
about the misties the the Misti the
misties flew the two-seat jet trainer
version of the F-100 each plane carried
Two fighter pilots one in the front was
the mission commander and the one on the
back was the Forward Air controller to
keep each honest those rule roles
alternated they flew low and fast over
the panhandle of North Vietnam Vietnam
and Laos single Fighters armed with only
a few hundred rounds for the 20
millimeter can cannons and 14 white
smoke marking Rockets
to be able to see them through the
camouflage they had to get right down in
amongst them so the loss rate was high
the first Misty Commander Major Bud day
who we heard from already today was shot
down early in the operation and spent
more than six years as a pow
with air refueling support from the
kc-135 tankers over the Gulf of Tonkin
Misty missions were long four to six
hours and laced with plenty of action
owing to high risks the Misty unit was
composed of only volunteers and each
Tour of Duty was short only 120 days
a high percentage of those who did more
than one tour were shot down
each Misty sortie was assigned flights
of f-105 Thunder Chiefs or F4 Phantom
fighter bombers if they had a really hot
Target
they could scramble gun Fighters off the
alert pad at Danang to come north and
work with them most high value targets
in the north were well defended with
intense AAA
once a Target was determined the misties
orbited just out of gun range and waited
for the fighter bombers to join it took
a few minutes in the orbit to brief
everyone on the Target and that gave the
Gunners plenty of time to pump up
adrenaline and exercise their trigger
fingers the Misti had to Mark the target
with a white smoke rocket and was the
first one down the Chute the Gunners
knew the drill as well as the misties
rolled in inverted and pulled the nose
down toward the target every gun would
open up within seconds as tracers
flashed by their canopies they lined up
to fire the smoke marking rocket
there was always one hell of a Rush a
real e-ticket ride now this was more
like it this was real Combat this was
what I came to Vietnam to do I had to
become a misty
how did I do it first of all misties are
volunteer okay volunteers okay okay so I
volunteer
so in January of 1968 my life changed
dramatically I was a Misti and on my way
to the action in North Vietnam no more
making toothpicks out of jungle trees or
upsetting monkey colonies
my new world revolved around heavy AAA
Flack truck Parks Bernie oil fuel dumps
storage bunkers and stopping the flow of
War material along the Ho Chi Minh trail
this was what I was here for
you God I loved it
yeah so they so you only had 112 that's
the standard tour was 120 days
120 days in Misty right
and the the you're going out on these
operations what's the chances you're
going out on a misty operation what's
the chances you're going to receive
enemy fire every time 100 100 percent
uh the Misty day well we could only do
three Misty missions in a row three of
them and then you were totally spent B
when you say in a row you mean three
days in a row three days in a row three
and these are four to six hours a piece
four to six hours however you'd wake up
you'd wake up three or four hours ahead
of time because you had a long
intelligence briefing what what was
going on up there uh what were the other
Mysteries uh reporting truck Parks uh
budget barge traffic burning trucks
whatever we need to be really up to
speed before you went up there and took
over
so there was a long there was a long um
a long intelligence briefing
and then you go out to the airplane it's
still dark
and you get in the F-100 you taxi out
and usually in Vietnam it's uh
it's kind of semi-foggy maybe a little
drizzle
kind of an eerie thing and just before
Dawn at Phuket every morning alone F-100
with light his afterburner
and off into the Merc
to North Vietnam
and every morning I'd hear that that
lone F-100 take off and wonder if
you know what his day was going to be
like
and you go up we had our own tanker
because we're if you're low and fast in
a jet you're burning fuel
and since you have your own tanker off
the coast it's just you then you could
do multiple refuelings and you could
still fly your mission
but it was kind of a kind of an eerie
solemn thing
I remember going through the chow hall
and the Vietnam combat chow hall but
you've experienced that too power to
eight powdered eggs and
greasy bacon and some some some stuff in
the morning chow hall and maybe you
would drink it a little bit before the
night the night before and you're really
not feeling all that good
and normally uh
you wouldn't want to you wouldn't want
to eat it look at that and I said let's
skip it you know
but I stand there and I look at that
food
and I think about how terrible it is and
then someday a little voice would come
to you and say dick you better eat this
because this may be the last meal you're
going to have for a long time
and then with that in mind you sit down
there and you woof it down and gag it
down as much as you can but then here
it's about a 20 minute flight you go up
and you reach on rejoin with your tanker
just off the coast of North Vietnam
and about 20 000 feet you need to take
on your load of fuel
and then the this this experience
between the time that combat started did
you back off of your tanker and you make
that turn
and you start descending on a 20 000
feet now you're going to penetrate North
Vietnamese airspace and you're going to
try to do it at a different place each
time
not for the routine
but it was very swollen the error was
generally very smooth
the most Serene thing you could ever see
and pretty soon the coast of Vietnam
which is normally kind of Farmland it's
rice paddies and things most peaceful
thing you've ever seen
and as she descended on a 20 000 feet to
hit the coast at low altitude where our
mission was uh you check your visor pet
your visor down your chin strap on make
doubly sure that all the seed ejection
safety pins are pulled out and in your
pocket and then all of your emitters are
tired out because you don't want to have
a transponder on or a beacon on
and then you set up for the Rockets and
the mill setting and then you arm the
guns and then you sit there for a
handful of minutes
and you think
God I want to want the next six hours of
my life is going to be like
and it's kind of an awesome quiet
Solitude feeling
and then you got it pumped up to 550
knots
and then all of a sudden
now this is kind of the the
light level was really low because it's
just kind of early in the morning it's
just on we just wanted we want to
penetrate it Dawn and we're going to be
there until noon but that first time you
have this Eerie feeling like you know
what is the next
six hours of my life is going to be like
and then all of a sudden all that
changes because the very first Gunner on
the shoreline sees you
and every bloody Tracer that he fires
you can see it really easy
and then there's a lot of guns on the
coastline and they know the drill and
Missy's coming
because we're up there every day
and then the whole Skies is full of the
most beautiful air
fireworks show you've ever seen this
massive
um massive display of
of
tracers and then you try to find maybe a
they called I've heard it called the
tear in the curtain to make your way to
make your way in bond
but then with the very first time
that that first guy opens up at you with
the tracers that little gland in my
shoulder I was telling you about huh
that's odd it is pumping and then it's
freaking Combat Baby and we're going to
be there in Mortal Kombat with my fellow
men for the next six hours
and I'll tell you what this guy loved
every damn second of it it was a big
challenge you know you kind of hide your
trucks and stuff and your War materials
to kill our soldiers in the South if
we're gonna freaking find it and I'm
going to round up some f4s and some
f-105s that come down there and bomb it
and take you out and if any of you guys
even have the thought of one of your
classic Russian gun sites six position
in a circle they're all classic Soviet
with 37 and 57 millimeter
uh and then there's the other one the 50
cal and the was it 14
zip guns and and then there's always the
everybody has an AK-47 and when you fly
by especially in the mornings all the
little Villages they all look like
sparklers and they're all shooting but
they're shooting
you know we're pulling a lot of GE
Jenkin really hard so they can't ever
they can't ever aim at us
and uh every once in a while we'd pick
up a small arms round
uh very rarely but then it's the big
stuff that would um you know blow your
whole airplane apart and then it was
fights on so are you waiting for the for
the fighter bombers to show up before
you Ingress uh you see there's an air
order of battle for the day a frag acorn
and we were assigned uh like the
like the other misties there were some
other targets that were identified that
we need to go up and make strikes
on that area
and then uh just before the day started
they were assigned
your assignment 105's a flight of 105s
or uh f4s called the gunfighters or the
f4s out of denang
they were assigned to us they'd show up
and leave Rendezvous and I already have
the Target and I go down and find it
identify it
and then we'd uh we'd brief them
you know the altitude the Escape Routes
what the winds were altimeter set in you
and that's a brief that you're doing on
station yeah when we finally join up
with them so would you have to in order
to find the target would you have to go
down right and look right and that was
the big problem that was mainly why we
had a Forward Air Control in North
Vietnam because the guys the guys that
would come up there they're not up there
all the time and they're high altitude
and a lot of times
I find that this is really unfortunate
that they would go and drop bombs on
Villages and stuff
especially at night they'd see a little
village and they'd bombed The Villages
and they'd say and the morning mystery
they come up and the controllers would
say hey they had a I said the guys were
up here last night and we killed 40
trucks on Brown route
and we go over there and there wouldn't
be any trucks on Brown route but there
was a village over here burning when we
put an end to all that
so that I think that we directed
the airstrikes against
legitimate military Targets on the Ho
Chi Minh trail
and that was good and sometimes they
identified it and they wouldn't have
Fighters so they would identify it and
then they would brief us the next
morning and we'd go up there and find it
now if you're up there almost every day
for six hours you get to know that place
like the back of your hand
especially the gun sites
the gun size accuracy
that varied dramatically
in fact there was a guy in Laos he was
on an edge of a real rugged car so he's
a 50 caliber we called him the kid on
the cars
and every morning we come up and wake
him up and
as we'd orbited him he would shoot
exactly 180 degrees
and he was the worst shot in the world
and it always looked at how do you get
all that ammo up there on this steep
cliff and why in the world
why in the world when he would he lead
us like 180 degrees around the circle
and when I'd have a new Misty pilot I
said hey I want to show you what a what
a 50 caliber looks like and so we'd fly
up there and the kid on the car seat
would fire and they wouldn't even come
any close and so forth but every once in
a while some of these gun crews are
really good
uh they would get us normally you could
see most of the gun sites and if you
could see them then you could avoid them
or you could not maneuver in such a way
and we'd name we'd give them names and
stuff
uh that basically if the guy was really
good and his camouflage you know this is
a major soviet-style Gun Site
if they were well camouflaged
and we came by and I had my belly up
looking at something else and they would
fire
and the Tracer would come those big 57
calibers of 37 caliber uh things you
know as big as a beer can it would come
by with that with that red Tracer come
to my really close and sometimes you can
actually hear the shock waves you know
like a uh like a baseball bat
around Europe and then they know that
they were really close
and if they were really close and very
clever and well camouflaged we freaking
had to go back and kill them at least I
did
and uh the one thing the thing about
combat if somebody is trying to kill you
and like the bombers in World War II
they just have to sit up there and take
it they couldn't retaliate against it
but I thought that was really horrible
but the Misty had the ability that if
you were good and you came really close
to me [__] we're going to come back
and take you out
and so I'd roll back roll back and
there'd be a ring around the gun side to
be slowly drifting away and then I'd
pull up just out of the range and I
think and then what the drill was going
to be after that
because I need to go out and get some
tankers but I'd come back
and uh we scrambled the gunfighters out
of Danang or we have a flight of f-105s
we could Rob from the guys going
downtown Hanoi or something I says hey
I got a target for you
it's an extremely aggressive Accurate
Gun Site and I want to take them I want
you to take them out for me
sometimes the Misty would try to try to
describe where the Gun Site was
uh by talking them into it so I didn't
have to mark them
okay guys you see the Gulf of talking
out there yeah we see that it's a big
river called the crank cave River okay
follow it up until it has a dog leg beam
you see that he says okay right at that
place and you try to talk on a little
road and right off there there's a field
and if and if I tell them
sometimes I could talk him into like a
truck storage area or something and they
could get that but if I'm trying to to
talk them into it verbally into a gun
site they almost never can see it
they say okay Missy this is your target
you freaking Markham man
now what you have to go to what altitude
to get a mark on a on a Gun Site well we
knew what the range of them of them was
and we just climb out of the range of
the 30 57 was a little higher 37 was a
little lower
and it was really interesting because
these these uh the shells that would be
six position and they'd all open up in
the long stream of tracers and they
they'd float up and they get slower and
slower and slower and finally the Tracer
would go out
and then you couldn't see him anymore
but then they would start down I guess
and then they would all self-destruct
boom boom boom boom little puffs of
smoke and we try to stay above that and
that's what four thousand five hundred
feet or something like that yeah four to
five thousand feet if memory serves me
right and so you're doing your best to
Fly Above That range right when you go
to Mark a Target do you have to go into
that range or can you Market from
outside no no you got to get in there oh
they know what the drill is
and it's up to you to put that white
phosphorus smoking uh right marking
rocket right on top of them and what you
want to do is find out what the the
drift is so you put the marking rocket
just upwind and when the white
phosphorus goes off it it blooms up and
hopefully it'll drift over drift over
the gun so when my first fighter down
the Chute he has a better chance because
they can't see him now and then he could
come in and drop his bombs
uh but it was
uh you know as a as a as a kid for the
first time you climb up on a high dive
at a swimming pool
and you walk out and all of a sudden
this 15 foot looks like 15 miles if you
look up what the hell am I doing here
and it takes all the courage you have to
walk out on the edge of the board and
jump off for the first time and
everybody's experienced something like
that
uh
it comes up finally the Mississippi
circle on him and they and they shot and
they missed the Misty now they know what
the drill is
and they know that if the first thing
they do if Missy marks them they're dead
and so other concentration is is to
knock the Missy out of the sky
and they're all waiting for you and
sometimes you'd have to wait because the
fighters weren't available then and then
they'd have to go out and refuel or
whatever
so you're circling them
and uh they know what the drill is and
set his ethnicities as soon as his wings
roll up past vertical
and sinners are past vertical and the no
starts down every damn Gunner knows that
it that they got to kill the kid they
got to kill the Misty because if they
get marked they're [__]
now there's a handful of seconds
because
uh there's a thing called lead if you're
flying along we could always Jake and
they would have a hard time tracking us
and give us the right lead to hit us
but there's about four or five seconds
where there's no lead requirement
because all I have to do is aim right at
the Missy because he's coming down the
Chute right at you there's no lead
there's no lead requirements or anything
and there's that handful of seconds
that's when you've got your nose at the
Target and you've got to keep it there
for four or five seconds to get your
rocket off yeah and and
there's an overwhelming urge to just
throw the rocket down there and get away
but then you keep thinking this is
important because how I Market how
accurately if I can use the smoke to
Blind them I owe that to the fighters
that are coming up there too
and so it takes a lot of willpower from
the nose finally comes down and then
they're all shooting then it's all
coming up your way
and and to roll out to pull it down
put the pepper just below the target
and then let it ease up and make sure
there's no yaw involved in the airplane
and you're not a lot of G because if
you're having if you're flying G the the
angle of attack will change your marking
and it's all that but it's that handful
of seconds and it takes you think
uh uh this is you know just don't throw
this thing out there it's like an
eternity
can you pull it up and then you
stabilize it and then pickle and once
uh smoke rocket comes out now the bad
thing is the Escape Route and once
you've fired fairly low at maybe a 30 or
40 degree dive angle and what altitude
are you at when you when you fire
um
1500 feet
[Music]
okay so maybe two thousand fifteen
hundred two you're well within range
okay now the worst thing you want to do
is you fire the fire the then you pull
off straight ahead over the target you
don't want to do that so once you fire
you roll the airplane about 130 degrees
to the right
and then you pull down into the ground
and and what you want to get is a is a
tracking solution that they have to use
some type of skill to be able to hit you
uh tracking now they've already had this
one chance where they don't have to do
any all they got to do is aim they don't
have to lead you
so you pull to the right and down and
roll Wings level now you're coming out
pretty low
but there's no way they can track you
because now there's a big angular
velocity and stuff and you're pulling up
and when you come back around you want
to look at your smoke
and it's either hit my smoke or
generally the fighters three or four
Fighters that are orbiting there is
absolutely no freaking idea
no confusion because that whole thing
the muzzle flashes just they almost
light up the world
and then then it's payback time
and the Missy pulls back up and uh you
say you know hit my smoke
and then you pull up around
and then lead rolls in and now they all
concentrate on lead coming because he's
got to do the same thing coming down the
chute
of course he can drop his bombs a lot
higher I was going to say can't he drop
from yeah six six or eight thousand or
something like that so is he out of
their range of their weapons no
by the time they pull out they're
probably down within their their lethal
range for sure
and now if if you're flying around and
you see the guy roll in there's no
there's no way you can tell because of
the angular velocities and stuff uh the
angle's off when he rolls in and drops
his bombs
now in his stack of bombs come off and
he pulls off and then you see in the
bombs fall and then you see these the
gun side the muzzle flashes uh
going up at him and they see them
and you see them down there shooting
like mad and then you watch the bombs
come and they see the gun sights the
bombs come
and then the gratification you get when
he hits them dead center and all of a
sudden the most configuration of dirt
and and uh it Nails the gun size and
then there's the guns are laying over
and all the bunkers are gone and stuff
sometimes sometimes they miss
so what we would do when David roll in
then I would then I would pull up in the
opposite direction and make a fake pass
at him and that was to draw fire away
from number two and he's coming down the
Chute and then we just do a Crossing
maneuver and they may be able to do the
same thing for three coming down to try
to try to draw some other firearm
and there's a handful of minutes that
it's pretty exciting
and in a in a four to six hour mission
how many how many targets would you go
after
uh it varied a lot depending on the
weather sometimes
it's usually a pretty it's usually a
pretty uh
pretty high workload
uh if you're not if you're you've had
your assigned targets
uh sometimes all they want to do is drop
bombs on a on a road to do a road cut to
on the side of a cliff and try to close
the um try to close the roads they did a
lot of that thinking they were going to
close down the Ho Chi Minh trail we go
down there in the afternoons we put in a
bunch of strikes and actually have a
road slide on a cliff
and I thought boy that shut down the Ho
Chi Minh trail for a while we come back
at dawn the next morning
and the road is fixed it didn't slow him
down at all the other thing that was
really fun is that is that the Navy went
out and they mined at some of the rivers
like the coin key River up there
and and they were magnetic mines
and when uh they were like when a boat
comes by it would trigger magnet you
know the magnetism of it and it would
blow up well these these mines would sit
up there and they get more and more and
more sensitive
and this this this was just fun I guess
so the first guy down the river uh first
guy in that morning we come real low
right down the river going real fast and
almost ever invariably we could trigger
off some of those mines behind this you
know just to go up and screw with them
sometimes
um good good over overview of what you
guys were doing up here
um
I got again you you profile some of
these missions in here here's one of
them where there's a
a down pilot
you say down in the jungle is one of our
own a fellow fighter pilot a warrior
he was still free and talking on his
survival radio so this guy got shot down
and you hear him talking our Creed was
that if you are free and want and
talking we will never give up on your
rescue
the rescue force that morning suffered
numerous delays in mismanagement before
helicopters could be deployed into North
Vietnam permission had to be required
from some kid in lbj's White House
it seemed the permission Giver was
asleep and no one wanted to wake him
which caused extensive delays at a time
when every second was critical
frustrations abounded on these on the
for those on the rescue team I had flown
seven and a half hours the day before
and would invest another seven and a
half hours before this day was over with
nerves ready to snap this disjointed
rescue effort continued and it was
already close to noon my relief Wells
Jackson Misty 2-1 had just arrived as he
was being briefed A call came from
search and rescue headquarters in Saigon
canceling our rescue and instructing us
to pull out all forces
I was incensed with this turn of events
but the orders had originated from those
much higher on the chain of command than
I a lowly captain
then it hit me
since I was the only one who could talk
directly to Jack the down pilot it was
going to be my job to tell him we were
giving up and abandoning him to the
North Vietnamese for certain torture
imprisonment and possible death I was
infuriated
what were they thinking
we were American fighting men and we
never give up
enraged I demanded to know who gave the
order to pull out
turns out it was a general in Saigon who
thought it was too risky and had issued
the order to withdraw
I thought since that general made the
decision to quit that General should be
the one to tell scotch03 that he was to
be abandoned
sleep deprived and Furious I ignored any
sense of military rank protocol and
demanded the general tell me the exact
words to use when informing Jack that
further rescue attempts were being
aborted
while we waited for the exact words I
finished briefing my relief Misty 2-1
and with a heavy heart left the area
knowing we were about to fail one of our
own
back at home base in Foo cat it was now
close to Sunset I sat slouched in the O
club disillusioned that my commanders
would could violate our most sacred Cree
if you are free and talking we never
give up
alone and heartbroken my only company a
couple of empty beer bottles I
contemplated my commitment to these high
risk missions
it was then that Wells Jackson Misty 2-1
burst through the door with a big smile
on his face
I had to wonder what the hell he was so
happy about
hey Rutan they got Scotch out
I could not believe my ears and blurted
what Jackson continued yup Scotch was
rescued seems the general could not come
up with the exact words to tell a fellow
Warrior he was about to be abandoned
perhaps the general began to realize how
such a decision could compromise the
long-term morale of all of us who fought
and died on the Ho Chi Minh trail
foreign
that particular Mission when they got
him out
say before that that morning
uh well actually the day before
we were up there and there was a flight
of f-105 it's not under our control but
I could hear him talking that scott03
the number three guy in that four ship
of final fives they were calling calling
and uh
there was no answer
so I flew over to the area that they
were working and just by a fluke
by glints maybe maybe just a second I
spotted the orange and white canopy in
the top of the jungle
you know as I flew up pulled up to come
back around it disappeared
and however I memorized to memorize that
spot before I took my eyes off of it
again so I pulled up and I called and
called there was no answer
and so then I pulled up and I did a die
bomb pass where I could talk to him
overhead diving right straight at him at
that point and I called Scotch and he
came back and he could hear me and he
could talk now there's just a handful of
seconds that we could exchange
exchange information where are you I
mean are you okay I said no I have a I
have my colleagues to have a broken back
and I can't move come and get me
now the sun was just going down and it
wasn't enough time to generate a rescue
Force
and so Steve amdor another fellow Missy
and I we'd already done a six and a half
hour mission
and we put Scots asleep that night and
told him we'll be back at dawn to get
you
and we went back to Danae and landed and
tried to organize a rescue force that
morning and then we took off at about
three hours of sleep we took off and
just right at dawn the next morning I
came across that thing with my
afterburner going
and uh called him and there was no
answer so I pulled up back around and I
dove at that spot
and then I could ask a question he can
give me the answer and then we'd pull
off and we'd go away so that's how we
were going to communicate with him
okay this was this was Dawn
this faithful day
it was long and disjointed rescue in
fact they'd shot up two helicopters the
helicopter would come in and hover
and they found him that night they
located him and they set up a flat trap
because they knew we were coming back
and every time one of the helicopters
would come into a hover jolly green and
hh3 Air Force helicopter they would
shoot and shoot them up pretty bad and
they did that to two of them and they
got away
there was an A1 Skyraider that was also
working the rescue that morning and he
got shot down and he uh
for some reason he tried to Dead stick
it into the Ben High River and he was
killed
so we lost two helicopters and we had
one A1 shot down and the pilot was
killed
uh
the whole morning was disjointed because
they had B-52 strikes coming in and they
pulled off our rescue forces numerous
times and let these big bombers
you know here these guys are 30 000 feet
they dropped their bombs before they
even go feed dry
and to try to you know hit some targets
uh that were near where we're working
so we got pulled off back and forth so
finally uh
the jollies the Jolly grains were trying
to to to come across the border into
North Vietnam and they couldn't get
approval
and I said something that was that was
probably not very
uh I said I said something that wasn't
very complementary about these guys that
wouldn't come in and get my guy
which turned out then I learned about
the fact they couldn't because of some
snot-nosed kid in lbj's White House that
had to approve it nobody wanted to wake
him up
and boy then the frustration level was
just uh
really high
you know there's targets that we'd have
but when when you're out there and
you're trying to find and Rescue
one of your own
then then that's totally different your
motivation different I kept thinking God
they could be me down there
you know
and so there was a guy named Don uh
angen and at hh3
now this is this is after the time that
Isis
uh you know I briefed him and then I
says tell me the exact words
you know if he's gonna
if he made a decision to leave this guy
to die well then damn it let him tell me
the words I mean you made the decision
you come up with the words to tell and
then a dawned on me hey
I'm the only guy that can talk to him
I'm going to have to tell him that I
thought screw him I'm not going to come
up with my words let the General's words
and then I left with a heavy heart like
he said
and as it turned out Wells came up and
they ate them General
changed his mind
and only this time when Engen came in
and hovered they put um
uh the guy's name was the PJ had been in
country three days I think
he was a two striper a PJ that he was
going to be down on the ground
and you know he was there just long
enough to hear all the horror stories
about being on the ground in North
Vietnam
and then he came into a hover and he
dropped the PGA down through the jungle
to try to find scott03
and uh I guess he roamed around and it's
all a tape it's an incredible tape
and Wells Jackson is talking about a gun
sight over there that's trying to lob 37
millimeter into the rescue area
and uh and Wells back seat he has a
photographer that went along with him
that day and the guy was six hours
and he was uh throwing up continuously
and over the inner phone they could hear
the kid throwing up
but he came into a hover anyway
Cali Sergeant Herman Kelly yeah
that's the PJ that's the PJs on the
ground
and uh he finally found he roamed around
and found him
and then now I had the vector the jolly
green order now it's all very quiet
there's no ground fire or anything he's
saying and he says forward forward
forward it says okay that's good drop
the box of penetrator it's long cable
with a special Pete you know what it is
a penetrator device kind of like a
bullet that can go down through the
jungle
and it goes down and uh it's Arden
Talent or air mentality puts the scott03
on the on the penetrator
and then everything's quiet you know the
guy's sitting there in a nice hover
engine is a coast guard
exchange pilot it's not an Air Force
pilot Coast Guard pilot
and uh he said okay
and then tally on the ground has a
little radio and he says okay I got him
uh you know pull me up
and then there's a handful of seconds
and you can just imagine he's sitting
there in a hover and the cable's coming
up oh so slowly and I don't know how
high it was it may have been
30 40 maybe 50 feet in the sky and then
they activated
the Trap
now they knew this time that the Jolly
wasn't going anyplace he was he was
hooked you know the other guy is weren't
hooked they just get away but they knew
that the jelly they had the choice of
either cutting the cable and leaving
and uh and England said later it says
guy how could you sit there under that
withering fire and he says there was no
way I would ever leave one my pj on the
ground
God I mean that was just his mindset
what an incredible person
and this cable come up and and Cali
would squeeze the mic button on his
little radio and he's been screaming
ground fire ground fire take it out take
it on ground thin in the background you
can hear intense automatic weapons fire
and tally told it later he looked up at
the at the jolly
and it was being from all different
directions being shot to crap I mean the
windshield was being blown out there was
hydraulic fluid leaking one of the
landing gears had just plopped out and
there was punchers of fuel pouring down
and pieces falling down off the airplane
and uh later on I asked tally I says
this is what a great thing you know to
save the helicopter you know you'd
sacrifice yourself to do that
and he looked at me
you know typical boy or this kid
he looked at me says oh no no sir it
wasn't that at all he says I looked up
and I didn't want the damn thing falling
on me
anyway
angan
he was awarded the uh the Air Force
Cross but it should have been a medal of
honor
and even today I'm still trying to work
that out especially since I found out
that an entire Vietnam war that all the
contributions that the that the Marines
I'm sorry not the Marine but the Coast
Guard this guy was a Coast Guard
Exchange spot that whole war and all the
participation by the Coast Guard in that
war there was not one Medal of Honor
winner
and I thought that's really a shame and
even today I'm assigned to write letters
and and trying to get that thing
upgraded because I think it would be
important that the contribution of the
Coast Guard should be recognized by one
of their Heroes and anger to do that
anyway they got him above the jungle
canopy and then he translated away and
it was just a few miles
and he just crossed the Ben High River
uh to there was a Medevac there called
the rock pile and they landed and that I
don't think that Jolly ever flew again
it was shot up so bad
man
um
uh we've got another situation
uh in the book and in this one
you're flying and there's another plane
another saber that's on fire and there's
a there's a general you don't know this
at the time but there's actually a
general
in the in the front seat yeah this is a
it's another rf4c you know same thing
that uh
well he was flying except it was a
reconnaissance work it was a recce
version of the of the Phantom
and so this guy
um their their call sign is is strobe
one zero
and so you're flying next to him you see
that they're on fire
and you you tell them hey you're on fire
and going to the book here it says
strobe one zero acknowledged our call
that he was on fire and stated we're
bailing out
this should have been a standard
ejection they were flying at 10 000 feet
straight in level at an ideal speed of
about 230 knots everything was set for
routine ejection and water rescue
which is interesting that you're talking
about a routine ejection and water
rescue that shows your mentality
I had never seen an object an ejection
up close the notoriously complicated F4
Martin Baker seat known as the
backbreaker would be something to
witness I ease the old hun to Route
formation about 30 feet out on his left
wing and waited for what seemed an
eternity nothing happened almost two
minutes dragged by before the rear seat
finally ejected later on I asked the
backseat of what had taken so long they
knew they were on fire he said that they
had taken out the checklist and reviewed
the ejection procedures
the general did not want to eject they
argued about the position of the command
ejection handle in the rear cockpit the
major upholding his duties wanted it in
the command eject position where the guy
in the back ejects the front seat pilot
however the general insisted that it be
left in the off position thereby making
each seat a single initiated ejection
the major reluctantly sat up straight
grabbed the yellow handle between his
legs and pulled giving the general
leaving the general to his fate
from my vantage point the rear cockpit
ejection was textbook and I remember it
vividly the AFT canopy opened and
separated cleanly clearing the tail by
at least 20 feet the seat started up The
Rails as the bottom of the seat cleared
the cockpit the rocket motor ignited
burned for 1.2 seconds and the seat went
straight up very stable when the rocket
stopped the small drogue parachute
released and the seat rotated backward
90 degrees as it cleared the tail
looking over my right shoulder I could
see the main C9 parachute canopy had
also deployed as it started to open the
seat separated from the back seat pilot
and kept right on going with the canopy
fully opened the pilot swung back
underneath I thought the whole thing was
neat as hell
until I looked back at the stricken
aircraft what I was about to witness was
chilling
it would leave an indelible imprint
which remains surreal and Unforgettable
to this day I was horrified to see the
front cockpit totally engulfed in fire
I saw an occasional Flash from a white
helmet that was barely visible through
the smoke and Flames the general is
sitting straight up as before but
motionless he seemed oblivious to his
circumstances huge Flames that resembled
giant blow torches streamed from the
rubber pedal Rudder pedal area at his
feet through the cockpit
around him and out through the now open
rear cockpit the fire had filled the
Phantom's interior and produced a dense
black smoke trail that obscured the tail
strangely the aircraft flew on terrified
I thought the general must not be aware
of the fire so I began to holler over
the radio strobe 1-0 bail out bail out
I continued to scream desperately but
the general just sat there doing nothing
the wings remained level in the aircraft
now began a shallow descent my God I
screamed why doesn't eject how can he
just sit there what the hell is wrong
then I figured it out maybe he couldn't
hear me I was too far away 30 feet so I
drove the Han right up next to the
burning cockpit and screamed again
strobe 1-0 bail out bail out
then Harlan yelled oh my God look at it
burn
frustrated and half in shock at what it
had just transpired not 10 feet from us
we moved in closer
so close the air pressure between the
two aircraft caused the fiery Phantom to
roll up into a right Bank as I pulled
back the F4 turned 90 degrees rolled
back Wings level and pointed itself
directly at the beach in a slightly
steeper descent
by then we could no longer see the
General's white helmet only a blackened
charred canopy the paint on the entire
nose was burned and blistered there were
a couple of small explosions in the nose
area that blew some of the panels loose
and sent other pieces flying off the
plane
the entire front end was a charcoal
colored Mass the orange and yellow flame
subsided their dense smoke streaming
backward over the fuselage
for some unfathomable reason I continue
to call strobe 1-0 begging him to get
out
even though it was obviously futile
we stayed close on his wing and at 500
feet the old Phantom gave one last gasp
pitched up a little then Dove straight
into the beach and exploded
I just couldn't let go Harlan screamed
God damn it dick pull up
I know Harlan's turn direction was the
wake-up call that saved us I might very
well have crashed right beside strobe I
pulled up hard barely missing some small
trees behind the beach pulling off to
the left and in a choking voice I told
water boy strobe 1-0 just impacted on
the beach
moments later Waterboy asked whether
there was any chance of survival
my plaintiff reply was negative survival
negative survival
now there's uh you have to kind of go
and debrief this situation and there was
a tape
there's a tape of this whole thing there
is
and and there's something that you talk
about in here you there's something that
you edited out of the tape was it some
words between you and the general what
was it
are
let me let me back up a second uh that
was remember the the Nixon he had an 18
minute Gap I had an 18 second Gap
uh first of all these were these were
extremely high risk missions that these
guys flew the recog missions they were
500 feet and they were straight and
level
and they would come up and we would
check in and they had their certain
coordinates for departure and their
routes and stuff and the Misty they
would check in with us and then we would
help them identify it sometimes they
needed some help identifying stuff
and so I would stay up above these guys
and watch them watch them with their you
know their photo runs straight and level
just getting shot up like that flying
straight and level up there it's almost
a kiss of death 500 feet yeah you just
never want to do that up there to fly
straight and level I would never fly
straight level the Mysteries had four or
five G's on us all the time janking like
mad so nobody could really predict where
we were going to be that's the only
thing that we could survive at all but
the one thing that I did know is that
these were extremely high risk missions
in North into North Vietnam by the
reconnaissance guys and they were flown
by lieutenants and captains
just like me
the company grit or the field grade and
would never be a general officer
so uh I had just come off the tanker
heading into North Vietnam and I heard
the call that we we taken a hit just
north of north of the case on I think
and we're coming out feet wet to get
feet wet and so I says wow okay well I'm
just coming out and they're coming
they're coming out and we're coming back
in so I joined up with them
now my perception was that I was talking
to the front seater
and the front seater was a captain just
like me right I had no idea it was a
dental officer I had no idea that I was
talking to a cni major the Mages will
take care of this General
in the back seat so my conversations my
perception was that I was talking to a
fellow captain that was sitting in the
front cockpit
and that wasn't the case
so we joined up with him and looked him
over he looked pretty good
uh and we had to get real close up
underneath them we could see there was a
little bit of fire going on up in the
Cameron Bay
nothing nothing bad
they were complaining about losing I
think they lost a utility hydraulic
system and it was getting really hot
but uh that was all
right and and I think that the general
was up in the North Vietnam where he
bloody well shouldn't have been but it
was his last mission it was his
champagne flight he was going to go home
and he wanted um they told me that he
could get an extra air medal if he flew
into North Vietnam which he wasn't
supposed to so this General Bob Worley
fighter pilot a good really a good guy
he wanted to go up there and on his last
mission and and bring back some good
information good photography and stuff
uh
and so all of a sudden
well we joined up with him he was about
I don't know 10 miles feet wet heading
south towards the Nang
and we saw the little fire and I was
having a conversation with a fellow
Captain not knowing that it was a
general
and uh
so we told them that they were on fire
or had a fire up in the nose
and we pulled off like I said like
you've read in the book in the route
formation right on his wing
and they took a lot longer than I
thought
to go ahead and I found out later that
they were arguing about now the general
said then I don't think the general
really knew that there was that there
was anything really bad enough that they
should that they should eject that's why
the argument was uh and I I'm sure that
he says
okay I'm going to get rid of this guy in
the back and I'm going to fly this
airplane back and save it because you
know if I lose the airplane and they
find out I was screwing around in North
Vietnam they're going to really frown at
me
and I think that was his motivation
to get rid of the guy in the back and
then he could be the hero and fly the
airplane back
which wasn't the case the problem on the
F4 Phantom was you can't get rid of the
canopy
it has a Pneumatic plunger that has to
push the Leading Edge up or else the the
wind the normal wind speed clamps clamps
it down you just can't unlock it because
it won't go anyplace you have to have
these plungers and I think when they got
hit in the nose that plunger was damaged
and so he didn't know it at the time
but the only way he could live was to
get the airplane back because this
injection system
without the canopy gone you can't eject
through it it's one of the Martin Baker
things
so that was in his that was in his mind
so when they finally decided to go ahead
and eject
uh
the fire hit him and he wasn't I'm sure
he wasn't ready for that
now my conversation the whole time was
with that guy in the white helmet in
that fire that's that was a conversation
we had had no idea that the guy was
talking to was hanging in a parachute a
couple miles behind us
uh so that was my mindset
but I often thought about what I was
saying what I was seeing and what my
reaction to that was
uh it's as why did I why did I say well
maybe he can't hear me
you know you know how absurd this is
hey hey [__] I didn't notice this
fire that the whole cockpit was on fire
I'm sure glad you told me about that now
I'm just going to go ahead and eject hey
I appreciate you telling me that I'm
freaking on fire in a cockpit's full
so you're sitting there and you got to
do something I just
so I called him you know straw 101
bailout bailout screaming into bailout
and
and then I says well maybe you can't
hear me I mean how stupid is that what
do you mean that in between 30 feet that
he can hear me on a UHF radio that'll
transmit for hundreds of miles I mean
it's just absurd that you know the
psychology of that and what hit you all
of a sudden
and then I drove in so hard that I uh
the air pressure
turned him other way he would have been
he would have crashed in the
you know like off of Tonka and this way
he cries right on the beach
and uh and not wanting to let go
and almost crashing right beside him
uh you know we we pulled up
and the water boy was the uh the
controlling agency the one that controls
Us in and out of the pack and BDA and
organizes fighter strikes and stuff that
was our controller and then all of a
sudden since he blew up now I'd seen a
lot of airplanes crash
and it wasn't unusual to see another
airplane you know a combat loss I'd seen
those before
and and it was always like okay well
okay another one another combat loss and
write it off and the war goes on
but as we're pulling up off to the left
they wanted to know survival and I said
negative survival
and then all of a sudden there was a
whole bunch of interest in this crash
site
they wanted security up there and they
wanted to get medevacs and they're going
to deploy a whole bunch of stuff and uh
what the hell is going on that's not
strange airplane crashes combat loss War
goes on
so we went back went back and found the
uh
the back seat are hanging in the
parachute only this time the wind was
really strong in the Gulf of Tonka and
then it was really rough
now we're down in South Vietnam South of
the Border
so the sand pan that was coming out was
coming out from the south
and it was a motorized sandpan and there
it was really rough and he was bouncing
so this is now a race between well the
guy's hanging in the parachute
and um see normally uh
you can get killed on somebody out there
screwing around they don't know what to
do now everybody's trained that
generally comes in and they know what to
do and how to take care of the parachute
you know all those issues you need to
get to get you out of the water into a
rescue craft
and then there's certain training Dave
you're moving through all that many
times soon
so all of a sudden we see this this
motorized junk and we looked we look at
it and it's uh what's a sand pan not a
junk motorized and he's booking it he's
going and he can see the guy hanging in
the parachute and he's going out there
so I go by and it has the South
Vietnamese flag on it
I didn't mean in that war that doesn't
mean square root of fox Rod Alpha what
the flag is
and so
Harlan that I talk about he was in the
front seat he was my student that day
and I was the instructor in the back
during this whole thing
and so I look at him and it says well we
can't let that guy get back to the pilot
and as I said okay we'll go ahead and
we'll go ahead and kill him
and so Harlan armed a gun and he came
back as we turn it on Final I'm thinking
you know maybe he is a South Vietnamese
and why don't we just scare him
so he did a low pass by and he just kept
going
and uh so it says okay well he's got the
message and then we'll just go ahead and
shoot him
and as we turn final the second time I
had second thoughts and it says well
Harlan why don't we put some 20
millimeter right across his bow
uh okay so Harlan did he rolled in and
he
put a stick of uh you know you know run
a strafe across his bow now it was
really neat he was going after I said I
don't know this straight went from right
in front of him and then he goes
and then he beat back beat back to the
store and then the jolly green finally
came in and rescued him after that
now we flew back to Phuket no I went
about another three hour mission that
day and I didn't get back until noon
and uh so we pulled into Phuket
and I noticed that there was every
kernel in the whole base was there to
meet us
and I told Harlan I says hey
I said I don't know what we did but it
must have been a major [__] up
and I couldn't remember that I'd been
anything really bad
but what were these damn Colonels here
for
and so it opened the canopy and the
first kernel up that's there says what
are you doing here you're you're
supposed to be in Saigon you're supposed
to be in Saigon what are your Landing
we're not supposed to land here is this
all mad at me
and then I told Harlan over the inner
floor and I says Harlan I don't know
what it is but it's worse than what I
thought
and then the guy finally found out that
uh that realized he says oh you don't
know who was on that airplane do you
know
Ricky guy fellow captain that you know I
said that's really a shame it should
have seen a lot of stuff
and he says oh my God
you didn't know that it was General
Worley in that airplane now everything
all made sense
and he says and that says oh yeah I by
the way I got it all on tape
because when he hired Mayday I started
the little tape recorder
that we jerry-rigged we bought it at the
hardware store and I've and I Jerry
rigged a plug that whatever I wanted in
my headset then I could record it on a
little cassettes that was just kind of
my idea
and so I handed it to him and the
colonel took it said you got it all on
tape wow and he was holding it maybe
someone says and they didn't know what
to do with it so he gave it back to me
thank goodness
and he says go get a Class B uniform on
there's going to be a t-39 scat back to
bring you down there's some generals
that want to talk to you down at Saigon
holy frick the last thing in the world
at this little up country poke pilot
wanted to do was hanging around with
four-star generals
uh it's with how many generals had you
talked to at this point in your
deployment to Vietnam I'm in general
shoot I'm a little Poe captaincy
so anyway the t-39 come up and picked us
up and on our way down to Saigon I
thought you know how to listen to this
tape and so I played it
and there was something in there that
was extremely inappropriate
just language-wise
Harlan is dead and I'll take that what I
said to the Great
recorded it over it and it was exactly
18 seconds long just like Nixon's 18
minute tape
and it's it's a damn good thing too that
I re that I took that out of there
because every one of those damn generals
wanted his own personal private briefing
and so I had to play it over and over
and over again and thinking
I'm sure glad to embraced that
uh but it was it was a shame too
along with that there was his he had two
daughters uh General Worley good guy
fighter pilot
and they called me some years later and
they wanted to go down and they wanted
to go to Vietnam where where their
father had died
and nobody could tell him where it was
the exact location
but I thought these two ladies they need
to go to the to an exact spot out there
to build a memorial and and have closure
right where their dad died
now I try to drag it out of my memory
and describe exactly you know turn left
here in this little town called fuknoi
and you go to the beach and you turn
left and you go 100 yards and that's
where he crashed
well as it turned out it was 100 yards
the other direction
that it but it didn't matter because
they went there and they sent me a
picture of a memorial and they were
hugging each other and it was it was
kind of a closure it was a nice thing
for him
now you got another another thing that
you write about in the book you write
about your friend Howie Howard K
Williams
what happened with him and what was this
this mystery phone call that you got can
you talk us through that yeah uh
the misties we were we were kind of a
unique group we were doing some highly
classified stuff
and we were separated from most of the
in-country fighter pilots that flew
those
um
toothpick monkey death making monkeys
definitions in South Vietnam
and sometimes we fly those missions and
there was troops in contact and there
was a lot going on
and we'd go in there Roland brought my
bombs and leave and I think
hey there's a combat down there you know
I wanted to be part of it what happened
I mean who doesn't come I want to know
the details of that and I just didn't
want to climb you know
uh fly back my airplane not knowing
about it that's why I wanted to go to
Misty
and and I found out about Miss Lee and I
says Hey I want to go there and it's a
volunteer thing and a guy says no one of
the requirements is you have to be a
flight lead
and it and I says okay uh well I want to
go to Misty I kept bugging my commander
the squadron commander and he said no
damn it return you're a you know a
newbie pilot here and you'll be six or
eight months four to six months before
you can even think about
checking out as a flight lead so I kept
bugging him and bugging him and bugging
him and he finally just got pissed off
and he says okay God damn it I'll give
you a flight lead check which I was no
more qualified or or experienced or
anything
and so I went out and I didn't do a very
good job as a flight lead
uh
in fact I think I got hit on that and in
country yeah an in-country hit which are
very rare getting hit from in country
the biggest thing to have it may be a 50
caliber and it hit it in the gun Bay
and as an example I screw it up I mean
here's the Target right we're going to
go in I got a flight of four and the
wind is blowing
so what does I do
uh little dick trying to be a flight
lead he chooses you know there's three
targets down there as an example and so
what I do I try I go and attack the
target that's upwind
so if it's upwind there's a bunch of
smoke and the smoke drifts over all the
other ones that they have to hit
you know like classy newbie screw up
and so the commanders the commander says
God damn it dick if you want to go to
Missy then you can go it's get the hell
out of here I want to see you again and
uh so then I enjoyed this
classified guys that had were we had our
own air-conditioned little trailers out
in our own little Cantonment area and
that's
the very end of the spear and if that's
where the action was and that's where
Dickey wanted to be boy that was so so
happy and enthralled with that that's
why I stayed to do a second tour to do
actually 100 Missions in misty
so then I went up and what I saw into
North Vietnam and the areas that we were
uh it was a different world
and there was a lot of a lot of ground
fire and a lot of a lot of targets
that had been hit
and we went back 35 years later
I went back with five guys that I flew
combat with
and I wanted to go back to that area we
call it the root packs and the North
Vietnam is often on about six different
areas you know two of them the Navy has
and then there's the ones up around
Hanoi and we were one of the ones down
in the southern Panhandle just above the
DMC it's called root pack one
so that was no that was our that was our
primary area that we flew in all the
time
and uh
I don't know where was I going with that
well I was trying to I was trying to get
to the uh what happened with Howie oh
with Howie okay this is now how I was
our I'm sorry
getting old and graveyard
uh how I was the Top Gun
at our gun school he was really good he
was a fighter pilots fighter pilot man I
had a cute little blonde wife and a
couple of little kids just
he was a cool guy
anyway he had it during Gunnery school
he had an engine failure
and he ejected
in Gunnery School
and when he got back he says well you
know how did it go you know everybody
said well why you ejected you know what
happened everybody wants to known and he
says well the only thing that happened
it says it jarred my he came back and he
says his his glasses were a jar his
sunglasses were a jar that's his only
issue and so now I'm up and missed it I
don't think it's cool as it gets huh
yeah he's playing
so it says how are you got to come up to
Misty and this is where the action is
now he didn't want to go
and uh
that I was so excited about what we were
doing and he's our Top Gun guy
and I don't think he was as
had the adrenaline or that little combat
gland as bad as I did
and uh
he finally acquiesced and he joined
Misty
and uh on his first checkout right he
got basically he got killed
uh him and him and Brian Williams two
Williams Howard Williams and Brian
Williams they were in an area called
chappone the very hot area up in Laos
and sure enough they got hit
on fire and Brian says the fire was
burning
from the engine compartment
all the way almost all the way into the
back cockpit
and they said
uh is this okay we're gonna have to get
out so they headed
a remote area in the jungle to eject
and he says so and Brian says okay I'm
going to go and Howard says okay I'm
right behind you that's
last words he ever said
and Brian
and I was up there flying another Missy
shorty and I heard heard this and went
tearing over there and the jolly green
was real close and they picked him up
picked up Brian that nobody heard
and I was really upset he says well
where's Howard did you see a parachute
you know and he didn't see anything
and I was kind of beefed about that but
it was Howard it was my best friend
and uh now he's down
and uh never heard never heard from him
again but they I did locate the wreck
site
uh dense jungle I didn't think there was
any human beings anywhere near the place
but he went down and he was he there's a
little Ridge and you could see with the
airplane clipped the jungle that was
burned and then went down into the
canyon and you could see the wreckage
and so every day I would go up there and
real slow almost kill myself trying to
go real slow and look down in there to
see if I could see anything but it was
just you know wreck site
I didn't hear a thing so I thought God I
gotta go up there and and uh on the
ground and see my my best body
so I made her I made an arrangement out
of uh Nikon Phenom in KP they have uh
have a Radar Site up there and they fly
helicopters that they put the uh the
road watch stamps you know you guys
you're you know your vintage they'd go
up there in the snake eaters like taco
just the Classic Snake Eater and they
put these guys in to watch the roads and
stuff and report back and forth and they
insert them and then they try to take
them out and stuff
so I contacted him and I says hey can I
get a ride in just you know on your way
in drop me off at the wreck side and
then when you're going to leave an hour
or two when they come back and pick me
up and bring me back and then I will
know what happened to Howard because if
I see an ejection seat or something
there then I'll know whether it's dead
or not
and so I had set that all up ready to go
and I'm walking around bumping into
myself too because I'm the summary
courts officer so you have to
uh you know all familiar with summary
courts because if somebody gets killed
somebody is designated as the uh this is
the guy that has to take care of his
personal thing and pay all his bills and
pack all of his stuff up and write the
letter to his wife and stuff
so that was my duty for that that I
didn't like and I'm all set ready to go
uh go over to Dan KP and they're going
to take me to the Rec site I get this
phone call
and it says
he says I'm a I think he said he was a
major so I'm a major but I can't tell
you my name
he says I know what you're going to do
tomorrow exact words
he says don't do it it's been taken care
of
and he said do you understand that
I says yeah he's been don't do it he's
been taken care of I understand that
and then before I could ask any more
questions uh he was gone
so I didn't go
now there was 18 15 to 18 years later
and I found out that uh
that they knew that Howard was dead or
they actually killed him and Laos they
killed everybody if you went down and
lost the policy was that they killed you
every single one of them there was no
capture and north then in North Vietnam
you're a value you're a valuable asset
now if if you bail out of North Vietnam
the civilians would kill you if they got
the got to you first
but uh in fact I got another story about
another f-105 pilot that I saw being
decapitated with machetes
right in front of my eyes
the thing about Howard
uh it was 35 years later they found out
what really happened that he was found
on the ground and two stories
uh one of them went up there and they
took his dog tags
uh one guy said he was dead he had a
broken leg and he was at the foot of a
tree
but I know what happened he was Howard
broke his leg and he was there and they
went up and killed him and took his dog
tags away from him and then he told the
farmer to bury him
and uh that they didn't bury him deep
enough and he was exhumed by a large
jungle animal and that's all they found
of him 18 years later when we finally
buried him in in Arlington
what his remains were
well what what was the f-105 pilot that
you saw get beheaded uh there was it was
in the coastal plain now the coastal
plain uh was flat right up to the edge
of the ocean and it was all Farmers you
know rice paddies and farmlands and very
sparsely populated and stuff
and we were on a misty mission one day
and I looked and coming right underneath
me was this thing that was on fire and I
didn't know that the 105 guy was even
there
and and it was a big shock the guy was
burning like mad and so I pulled up and
I could see he was trying to make a turn
towards the water
and fairly low altitude
maybe three or four thousand feet or
lower
and I wasn't talking to him or anything
but I'd more or less joined up with him
kind of high to watch him now I knew we
realized the thing was on fire burning
like man this f-105 thunder Chief and he
was trying to turn to get to the water
and then you know it was kind of like a
rooting section that's two Misty's in
the airplane you know come on hang in
there you know you're going to make it
you're almost there you're almost there
and then there was a big explosion in
the airplane and it rolled upside down
and the pilot ejected
and he was high enough that he got a
good shoot and then the airplane the 105
went over and when he finally hit the
ground it looked like
I don't know 10 cans of Napalm had made
the biggest Fireball I've ever seen
and so then now he's fairly low altitude
he's hanging in a parachute
uh
it's like so I came around to to Circle
him and you could kind of see you could
see the shadow
that the parachute didn't make and you
could tell kind of how high it was and
so I timed it so I came around and based
the final and and I came by you know
within
I don't know uh dragging the wing in a
wingtip in the you know I mean really
low
20 feet maybe right by now he this is he
landed in the rice paddy he took his
helmet off
he was taking his helmet off and he
waved at me as I went by and it was so
close that I could recognize his face
and I notice that there's a whole bunch
of other Gunners that were just shooting
like mad
and so we pulled up higher back around
and then it was the strangest thing I
could see him in the rice padding
and there was a perfect circle a black
circle around him
and it was it was all kind of collapsing
on his on his porn that's his black
circle and that was the black pajamas
everybody had this black silk pajamas
everybody that would work that they wore
up there and then he started running and
this thing collapsed into a kind of a
heart
and in my next pass I came around really
low again
and uh the farmers
the farmers were on him and they all had
machetes and they were chopping him up
and uh I pulled up and then you have
really mixed emotions because I had the
ability to kill every one of those
people you know my 20 millimeter I could
kill her one of those farmers
but then you don't know if the if the
fighter pilot was was alive or not
probably wasn't
but you know there's no way you can take
any risk and then you pull up you have
really a heavy heart holy crap
uh
you know a pretty emotional thing
uh there was a there was also another
rescue there was another shoot down that
was I don't know maybe a number of weeks
different
uh here again it was another f-105 pilot
and a wingman
and he had his wingman and uh
and he got shot down
and I went tearing up there and found
his parachute canopy on the top of a
ridge
uh it was a
ran off the quaint there was a quake
River South Fork of the cranky River and
there's a little village down there and
it was a very steep slope that went up
to the top of this Ridge and as I came
over
came over I looked at it and I can see
his parachute
and so we so he came around now he's way
man it's with him and we're talking and
and I made a really a bad decision I
really screwed up and I still feel
really bad about it today that I made a
mistake that I shouldn't have
and that is I should have sent him
to get the to get fuel from our tanker
right then
but the thing is that I could see the
people in the village and they were
starting up the hill
and so we took turns uh trying to put
some stray I wouldn't strafe into people
but I was putting straight between the
people and
in the pilot and I couldn't see his his
parachute anymore and uh he never came
up on voice either
and so we were both doing that instead
of sending him out to get fuel or
leaving him there to keep the
well we got the rescue going and I could
have went out and got fuel but all of a
sudden we were really involved in
keeping you know the people away from
them so we could set up a rescue
uh
I realized
it should have done this to start with
just a major amateur screw-up on my part
I still feel bad about it today
is that I didn't check and see how much
fuel we had you know what's your fuel
state
and we were both ran out of fuel at the
same time so both of us had to leave
and go out to the tanker and we came
back
there was no voice anything
and the 105 pilot
later on I've tried to find out who
these Pilots were and the guy that's on
the top of the ridge
I found that he had died he never made
it back as a prisoner of war but the guy
that was in the rice pad he did
and I don't have their names right now
and that it's not important but
anyway I was wrong about that and and I
found out later that the guy got killed
and he did get chopped up by the farmers
and the guy on the top of the ridge he
got captured and you know he made it
through prison or war and I found out
about it when they finally got released
in nineteen 73 I think it was
so
as you're doing this and again there's
incredible detailed stories in the book
and about these these missions that
you're doing
um
I'm gonna fast forward a little bit to
well I guess it's a pretty notable
mission for you
you were basically doing a test of a of
a theory of bringing guys up that you
work directly with is that right
one of our biggest problems
uh is Target accuracy
and you know I'd hang it out and find a
really great Target I find a barge I
found a storage area
and uh
we have a flight of
uh I don't know
maybe it was a coincidence but my
perception was that the f4s could barely
hit the ground much less my target
and it was not unusual that the that we
put a flight of f4s in on the Target and
my BDA was that uh uh there was no
ordinance hit within 10 000 meters of my
target no visible damage
it was very frustrating you have a
beautiful Target and they come in and
they couldn't hit anywhere near it
sometimes
sometimes they get so frustrated uh I'd
go down and the messages would do this
they weren't supposed to
we had our hard deck that we're supposed
to and I get so frustrated I go down in
the trucks that they couldn't hit I go
down and take out a couple of them with
my
with my two 20 millimeter cannons
and after giving that BDA I says and
just before they'd leave frequency I'd
pull up and say hey I got an addition to
your uh to your BDA
now we couldn't claim it for ourselves
we'd all get fired
but it's war and and damn it the
structure current bullets are going to
carry or kill our kids in the south
uh you know it's worth taking a risk I
thought
and so by the way uh I want to revise
your BDA you got two trucks killed
didn't make any sense
but the but the so this new idea was to
bring up guys that you different
aircraft that were you thought would
have a better chance of hitting targets
okay now we're frustrated about uh the
ability to hit the targets and that was
a big ongoing frustration we'd find it
Market accurately and nobody could hit
it pretty fat
that's a side note happened once and I
don't know why there was a flight of uh
Navy a4s off the Kitty Hawk
uh nomads
and I never worked the Navy because you
know I don't know what the Navy was
doing in an Air Force area but there
they were and I had a what I looked like
was a storage area and had bunkers and
stuff looked like there's fuel or ammo
storage area pretty good Target
and so wow the a4s would come up and
Nomad would check in
and you know they don't sound
differently the Navy would sound
different than the Air Force guys
so I said okay I got a bunker storage
area and I described a Target to them
and it says okay you know Green them up
arm them up guys get ready to go because
I'm gonna I'm into Mark so I pulled up
went around put a nice Mark in the
target
and uh I said okay hit my smoke
and I waited and waited and waited and
finally the smoke excuse me started to
dissipate and go away
and ask him
and ask him I said hey you know Nomad is
a is there any problem do you see my
smoke he says oh yeah I saw your smoke
Misty but I was waiting for it to get
the hell out of the way so I could see
what the target was
I just had never heard of that before I
mean this is really strange the Air
Force guys don't do that they just want
to come up there and piss off their
bombs and get their counters and go home
early
some of them
and and he says oh misty I see what
you're looking at
wow now he took over you know normally
the Ford air control and we control the
strikes and stuff he says Ah I know what
it is he says Ah okay and he described
it to the other his through his his
flight and he says okay two you put your
target your bombs there and three and so
forth and he controlled the whole thing
and I'm sitting back and things is wow
is this really cool
and uh they did hit an ammo's thing and
it burned for a couple of days and I
took some pictures of it and wrote a
nice letter to the to the Navy for God's
sake
and they invited us to the Kitty Hawk
and we went out there and spent three
days and combat operations off Yankee
station just because of we wrote up a
nice letter
it was really interesting these nomads
another thing I found the Navy
has a camaraderie between attack Pilots
and uh
and fighter pilots
camaraderie
and they were you know hanging out with
them for a while and every one of them
was having an argument about something
and he says he says Ah Jake goddamn he
says you're talking like a fighter pilot
a guy says take that back you know and
they're really arguing wait a minute I'm
a fighter fighter
but it was really a cool experience that
we had with them
so anyway what we wanted to do this day
is that
now there's guys in that
that draw bombs in South Vietnam
they're working troops in contact and
you've got to bloody you just don't piss
bombs off around like we do up in North
Vietnam
it has to be very accurate because it's
troops in contact and there's other
friendlies on the ground and the Ford
air controllers in the South make great
you know they go to Great Lengths that
we don't go and bomb our own people
and so now these guys could really hit
targets
and so it's my my buddy Chuck Shaheen in
fact we were kind of high school buddies
in some way we come from the same area
around Dinuba and we should chase the
same girls
and so forth so anyway chuck had
chuck had finishing up his first tour he
might have had I don't know maybe 60 60
sorties and I was working on 118 or 105
I guess
Miss emissions
and I had about five more to go before I
was my normal rotation
I says hey Chuck this is your champagne
flight hey how about two you know I'll
go with you in your back seat you know I
know it'll be your champagne flight
it'll be a little article in the Orange
Cove register that says two Hometown
Boys complete complete
combat tour and you know whatever little
blub and some little pulled out
newspaper I thought that's all it was
going to be
so I had this this is going to be a test
and so Chuck and I were going to go up
there and find a Target now these are in
country guys they hadn't benefited to
North Vietnam
and so I said now we've got to find a
real safe Target for these guys you know
there's some areas that you don't take
newbies into and some in really in some
intense area and so we're looking around
for kind of a benign area and the best
we could come up with is some goddamn
truck parked beside a karsh wall up
there by a little river and a little
road and this truck wasn't camouflaged
or anything
that should have been a clue right away
so finally we looked around and he says
well this is about the best we can do
but now this is a test this guy the
in-country guys and they sent up some
fighter weapons guys the guy's been
through the the top Air Force's Top Gun
School uh fighter weapons Nellis we call
them patch wears guys with their their
patch that they've gone through the
wider the Top Gun school they're guys
really good
so there were three of them then he'd
come up and we briefed them
and uh
I guess they could see the truck
and uh this guy says okay uh leads in
and he rolls in he misses bat as the
force did he pulled off
missed the damn truck he said oh let's
say I'm sorry I forgot to reset my
altimeter well [__] this is okay to
and he had some other excuse that his
Mill his site didn't work right and he
he missed on saw the long and short of
it is the three expert patchworks for
bombing accuracy you know the first guys
should have taken that truck out you
know they could drop it right in the
guide the truck's glove box if they
wanted to what the hell is going on
so all of them all of them missed now
right then our test was over and it
should have stopped it right
I should have stopped it but however
that damn truck was still sitting down
there
and that's when I'm going to take this
to the book you say we couldn't bear to
fail three passes same results and no 20
millimeter hits on the truck Chuck
decided the Misty fact should give it a
shot
someone should have reminded us that
when the 20 millimeter guns are Beyond 3
500 foot slant range the bullets just
tumble and are rendered worthless until
now we had all flown above 4 500 foot
hard deck unwilling to deny ourselves
this stupid truck
that seem to be just sitting there
taunting us Chuck went in if the patch
wearers couldn't do it we would
however we were we were the Forward Air
controller not the fighter bomber and
what we're about to do was in direct
violation of standard protocol I checked
the altitude indicator The Three Degree
dive angle put us flat and right next
right on top of the road the karst cliff
was now a blur close and right next to
me
we were low enough that I could even see
the Pebbles on the road this was a no
kidding low angle Luke Gunn School
strafe pass chuck had the throttle in
full burner burner real steady as only
Chuck can fly in the Weeds now he opened
fire and put a long concentrated burst
of 20 millimeter cannon right on target
I could not see the truck from the back
seat but was certain he plastered it
great we got some BDA the test was
successful the champagne Suite even
though the details were going to be
fudged a bit fudged hell in reality this
mission was a total failure
what happened in the next two seconds
would nullify everything we had done
Chuck came off the trigger and started a
hard climb as the high G came on there
was a loud bang under my right seat it
sounded as if Pete Rose had hit the
bottom of the fuselage with a baseball
bat and a home run swing there was a
whoosh
as my rear view mirror was filled with
fire when we pulled up I could see the
fires glow on the cliff wall looking
around I determined there were no good
options for an ejection I'm afraid it's
Hanoi Hilton here we come the drop tanks
had gone dry and Chuck called for a
heads up as we were going to clean the
wing and jettison the external fuel
tanks pylons and Rocket pods as we
pulled up the other f-100s joined us and
reported we were torching and confirmed
it wasn't an internal fire Chuck pulled
it out of burner the And The Angry red
fire in the mirror changed to a white
Vapor the afterburn or flame had ignited
the fuel stream and without it the fire
choked itself out the fire was out but
we were hemorrhaging fuel at a PR at a
prodigious rate there was talk about
turning off generators transfer pumps
looking for a tanker Etc but no
practical solution presented itself as
we looked ahead at the coast coming up
in the distance and watched the fuel
gauge rapidly unwind it was painful full
obvious the gauge would read empty
before we reached long before we reached
the water
all we could do now was reflight the
relight the afterburner and use the
remaining fuel for Speed before it
completely gushed out hoping we could
still make it to the safety of the Gulf
of Tonkin
the guys on our wing looked closely to
see if the fuel was running inside the
fuselage where it might blow us out of
the sky upon relighting the afterburner
they let us know it didn't look like it
but there was no way to know for sure
fighter pilots like to fly close
for some reason it seems the closer you
get the more help you can lend to
stricken comrade
as we look down at the small farms of
the coastal plain knowing farmers were
waiting with machetes in hand this
decision became a no-brainer Chuck
calmly called okay we're going to
re-light the burner
we had never seen two wingmen go from
close fingertip to high forward spread
root formation so quickly those guys got
away from you Chuck mumbled something
about candy asses and if those
patchwares had hit the damn truck we
wouldn't be in this fix he pushed the
throttle out board and relit the burner
the white Vapor stream in my mirror
again turned red with fire the wingman
said no sweat it's only torching wow
some torch it was only seven it was over
700 feet long we were accelerating in a
slight calm climb low on fuel with wings
clean and going like stink
I think we may have gone supersonic
Chuck's decision to re-light the burner
was a good one and it looked like we
might make it to the water Pilots seemed
to prioritize things only after
returning to Phuket did I remember
hearing a loud rattlesnake sound in the
headset and notice something on the
glare Shield our threat warning system
was showing a Sam missile it was going
wild surface-to-air missile launch
flight panel was lit up like a Christmas
tree we were four f4s flying straight
and level to the coast a perfect Target
but no one in our formation gave this
warning more than a plastic passing
glance normally we would have called Sam
Sam and broken for the deck
afterward the patchware lead told me yes
I do remember that I just reached up and
turned it off for some reason the enemy
did not launch the Sams they probably
thought we were going to die in the fire
so why waste a missile
I believe most Warriors during times uh
during the intense heat of combat
resigned themselves to the likelihood
that survival is improbable
as I sat there watching the torrent of
fire behind us the unwinding full fuel
gauge and the distant and that distant
Coast growing nearer deep in my psyche a
small glimmer of hope emerged maybe we
can make it we might actually get out of
this alive not dead and not as pows
halfway to the safety of the water I
made a promise to myself that if we
could make it to the coast and eject and
get rescued I would not be coming up
here anymore this is my 105th Misty
sortie almost twice that of a normie
normal Misty tour no one could ever say
I was a coward or a quitter
my next action had to be done perfectly
I had often visualized what it would be
like to eject on that violent rocket
seat riding it up and out I had studied
and trained for each of the procedures I
even joined a skydiving club and
completed 50 sport parachute jumps I
couldn't have been better prepared I'd
always been paranoid about my personal
parachute and made it clear that no one
else was to touch it ever
I would meticulously adjust the straps
to my frame since I had practical
experience in skydiving I was well
acquainted with the agony to the groin
area and the twins that resulted from an
ill-fitting harness a perfect fit was
critical
and was always on my mind
prior to my objection I considered a few
things but not in any sequence I
remembered running out of fuel chuck had
the Hun in full afterburner and we both
watched the fuel gauge unwind to zero I
always wondered how accurate those
gauges were and was about to find out
as the needle passed empty the engine
quit
this was not a sudden flame out but
reminded me of a pilot slowly pulling
the throttle back to idle however the
RPM did not stop at idle but continued
to unwind I recalled that there were a
lot of towering cumulus clouds off the
coast Chuck and I searched for an area
to eject and as soon as we spotted a
break in the clouds we knew it was time
the hc-130 Hercules search and rescue
plane Crown six had just popped into
view which was comforting during the
course of this entire catastrophic
Mission my cassette recorder had been
running but I neglected to remove the
tape and put it in my pocket prior to
ejection bummer
as soon as we made it to the gulf I
experienced an odd sense of calm I
realized this would be my final combat
mission
this was the first time I truly believed
I would make it out of the war alive
I was going home to see my family all I
had to do now was simply eject and get
rescued
I had complete faith in my equipment the
weather was good and the gulf glass
smooth and inviting was welcoming me yes
this was going to be a piece of cake
we had the ideal speed and altitude
necessary for a successful ejection
I said well Chuck it's time to go
I reminded Chuck about the half second
delay on his seat he responded no if you
go first there's no delay I began to
argue but fought better of it
okay now visor down straps tight elbows
in
head back hard on the head rest
I closed my eyes lifted the seat handles
and while squeezing both triggers
wondered what the next five minutes of
my life would be like
I wanted to avoid being anywhere near
the Hun's point of impact my rocket seat
fired and the e-ticket ride up the rails
was slow smooth and wonderful it worked
once clear I kick the seat away from me
and my shoot opened with a jerk looking
around I saw three f-100s Crown six and
a couple of f4s that had joined the
orbit I looked around for Chuck but
didn't spot him or our crippled hun
I could only assume chuck had waited a
while and ejected inside a cloud I
retrieved the survival radio turned it
on and expected to hear my shoot locator
beeper but heard nothing I had made two
emergency ejections in my lifetime and
the shoot beepers failed on both I tried
to call but couldn't work the damn thing
with my helmet on so I put the radio
away
the next item was the four-line
parachute cut sure enough the conical C9
shoot canopy would oscillate side to
side as air Spilled Out one side than
the other I love skydiving was eager to
test the four line cut cutting four of
the 28 lines would allow air to escape
in a controlled Manner and stabilize the
canopy I grabbed my government issued
hook blade knife and reached for the two
shroud lines on my right and cut them
next I grabbed the two left hook hook
the knife around the Shroud lines
cutting those two clean
but to my horror there was another cut I
had accidentally accidentally cut into
one of the four suspension risers
I slowly turned to survey the damage and
saw the nylon web Riser was cut ninety
percent of the way through had I cut it
completely the Chute would have
collapsed and I would have streamered
into the Gulf
my heart was in my throat my God fly 155
Misty missions and die by my own hand
I think Jonesy the first Misty to fly a
hundred missions did the same thing on
his final mission bailout do not give
fighter pilots knives much later someone
in the parachute shop got smart and took
away the knives from the flailing
fighter pilots and replaced them with a
four line release system that required
no cutting hanging in the Chute I took
one last look at North Vietnam
remembering all that had happened to me
during the past eight months as the
realization that I would not be
returning to a cold I was flooding
flooded with an unanticipated sense of
relief
I remembered to deploy my raft in my
survival kit but was so shaken from the
knife and parachute episode that I had
forgotten to activate my underarm life
preservers until just before hitting the
water without them the weight of the
survival gear would have pulled me
straight to the bottom of the gulf
sinking me like a brick I barely had
time to inflate one side as my feet hit
the warm clear water with no wind my
shoot settled right on top of me what a
mess I struggled to untangle myself
pulled the raft over and boarded
I attempted to relax and enjoy the quiet
Solitude as a new member of the
exclusive Gulf of Tonkin Yacht Club
it was amazing how clear the water was
and how good survival smelled
as I as I read
as I read these uh these ejection
stories I'm always surprised that you
guys like have time to think about it
and set it up kind of I always in my
mind I always pictured ejections you
know you get hit and you have a second
and you just pull it you go and and you
guys are sitting there thinking like
okay well looks like we're far enough we
got it a good altitude you have time to
think about it on this particular
incident there was a there was a lot of
time so that you know that we talk about
about the warrior ethic a real Warrior
if he worries about making it home he's
not where this [__] is a word they might
as well just stay home
and if you're going to go up and do
Warrior type things you have to accept
the realization
that you're probably not going to make
it and once you do that
then you can become
an effective Warrior you can focus on
the job that's right and and on on fire
or burning out there and I thought maybe
I was going to make it for the first
time I thought
because I had this premonition
about uh about being captured in fact I
used to go down into our intelligence
session where they could get a lot of
classified information and I was
surprised about how much they knew about
the prisoner of war status
even the interrogators in their name and
the new guy Village and what was going
to happen to you and those rope tortures
and stuff that was very very familiar
with that and it was it was like a
premonition and when we got hit and
pulled off I thought
this is it man
uh what are they calling the rat or
something I said well I think I'm going
to be able to meet the rat now
and then all of a sudden that full
transition that they we may make it to
the water
and then for the first time I thought
I'm gonna make it
and since I'd done two tour almost two
tours nobody would give me any problem I
says man if I found everything that I
needed everything I wanted to know about
you know maybe it's a selfish thing
could I be one of those Warriors could I
be one of those guys that flew those
missions over Nazi Germany when three
out of four of them died
uh did I have the did I have the courage
can I really do that
and I found out and
having that information to me
subconsciously from my own personal
psyche was really important
and I read a lot of other things too
I made a survey
some fellow fighter pilots
and it says
the thing is what happened when you
first started to be shot at the very
first reaction the very first time and
we talked about it in the book a little
bit
the first the first reaction was the
audacity not that I'm scared not I'm
going to drink away and and duck down
between my knees or whatever it was the
audacity of that son of a [__] to shoot
at me
that's the first reaction
and maybe that's uh
I don't know maybe a rite of passage
into being a warrior so what was the
survey
oh it was it was uh the survey that I
uh they were just mainly fellow fellow
fighter pilots and I tried to ask some
of the the people
that were uh that would that had ground
ground compact IQ did Jacob uh what was
their reaction but I wasn't able to to
really that was an informal thing I just
wanted to know about it it was I unique
or was this very very typical of what
happened when you first get shot and I
found that it's probably fairly typical
that there wasn't any of the guys that I
knew about that I flew with when they
first got shot
did the
the duck down and screamed from my
mother or
or whatever is this the audacity and
then
if you survive that you're a warrior
and I'd I would like to think that maybe
that was a pretty common thing too
and on all aspects of
of Mortal Kombat with your fellow men
so that was your last
combat operation Vietnam
uh so what what happened after that I
mean after that you do they did they
give you an option and say all right you
know you can you can head home now uh
well I still had my one year tour and I
was uh I only had about
I don't know a week or ten days now the
misties if you're involved in something
like that nobody give us any crap how
about our illegal hats or our illegal
mustaches or I saw a picture of your
mustache yeah
illegal any goddamn thing you wanted to
do you know there was always some spit
and Polished kernel that would come up
and give us and give us a bunch of crap
about
things that are not really germane to a
combat operation in the jungles of
freaking Vietnam
I'll excite in my shoes or something
like that
and it says okay Colonel well why don't
you this is I'm scheduled for Misty one
one in the morning why don't you take my
mission for me and I'll stay home and
clean my shoes
that's okay cool so basically if you're
in if you are in an environment where
you're probably not going to make it
anyway
uh that was your mindset
we did a bunch of other stuff we
acquired our own DC3 a whole DC3 and we
and we go back and forth to Hong Kong
anytime we wanted to
we're supposed to have a one r r where
you meet your wife in Hawaii the guys
that were married would go to Hawaii
well we go in and Forge papers
or one of them was
uh we go down to the personnelers
they I don't know the admin office and
they had these forms and one of the
forms was a
for emergency leave
and so we got a real one and we looked
at it and somebody had a typewriter and
so we could copy that that form nobody
ever checked on it I mean if it's an
authorized form
and so uh in my example
you know we made up authorization some
Colonel's name and it would always have
fun like he could sign his name at the
left hand or the right hand you know
I mean it looked official but it was
phony as hell because we just made him
up and I used one of those and I went
down to the uh the cargo area there at
Phuket and I handed this and within 24
hours I was back in the sack with my
wife in Sacramento
this was after you got shot down no no
oh that was just normal it was during
the during the eight months that I was
there we were just took this emergency
leave now we go to Hong Kong if we
wanted to you know nobody messed with us
at all the only thing that we couldn't
Forge was pay
uh you're probably lucky you couldn't
yeah but anything otherwise you would
have probably they probably would have
caught that one no they would have
caught that one and that wouldn't have
been right any but but as far as
anything else we'd go and do whatever
the hell we wanted to
and and not only that the misses were
known for uh
uh oh I gotta give you something too
it's our calling card
uh we can do whatever we want to so I
went down and I spent seven days at home
which is totally illegal you're not even
supposed to go home at all but my
emergency leave papers worked just fine
and so on Travis Air Force Base where my
wife and my one daughter was there
uh I went back and I gave him my
emergency leave orders and the
dispatcher there at the military
transport or mass terminal
he says okay you and your wife uh go
back and have a nice steak dinner at the
club and the bottle of wine and come
back here at 10 o'clock and uh you'll be
on your way we got a flight going out
for you
and so I did and like I said less than
24 hour I think in 20 hours I was back
in Phuket I thought you know I could
I could almost commute to this thing
so it was
uh it was really a devil may care you
know he just we're misses we do all this
stuff and nobody's gonna [__] with us
yeah on the ground or in the air now
let's show you my calling card
you'll get a kick out of this
it's uh
two sides I think you could look at that
maybe read it so side one says
get fact by a super fact
because they were the super Savers they
called them super facts get fact by a
super fact called Misty
for appointment contact Hillsboro OR
Cricket what are those what are sales
those are uh Airborne command Airborne
well uh air traffic control for the one
of another word
easy terms flak-free areas optional at
extra cost specializing in Sam's trucks
Supply areas and rest caps
then on the other side side it says do
not make rapid movements this man is a
trained professional killer hired by
your government to seek out and Destroy
enemies of the state he has nerves of
Twisted blue steel and must be handled
very carefully when done so he becomes
very docile you are advised to give him
the love and care he needs so badly
signed U.S Department of Defense you can
keep that please outstanding
uh so what happened so now the war is
over for you the war's over for me and
then I I got sent directly to another
war that important War
uh a war that if we'd lost we'd lose our
flag
and that was the Cold War
and then right out of the jungles of
Vietnam I found myself sitting in the
same F-100
with the one Megaton thermal nuclear
hydrogen bomb on the center line pylon
sitting in a bunker with a Target
someplace on the other side of the Iron
Curtain for four years and were you
stationed in England at this time
station in England
so how long uh what's your schedule like
well a schedule it was a three it was a
three-month rotation you spent uh a
month at home you know family and
training and and then we spent a month
at Willis in North Africa doing Gunnery
training
you know dropping bombs and whatever
and then you spend another and then the
third month you're in a bunker someplace
just waiting to make the flight wait
right out of right on right next to the
Iron Curtain with a Target on the other
side someplace like in Turkey or in
Italy
so that was the the three
uh the 90 day or this 30-day rotation
did you ever get uh spun up what was the
closest you came to launching did you
ever get the the call like oh it's go
time
well if you can imagine there's 12 of us
12 we call them Victor alert 12
airplanes hot cocked
with us uh crypto code release from the
president to be able to arm that weapon
and deliver it as you can imagine
nuclear weapons are very closely
controlled and rightfully so I would say
and uh
I would set on alert
and I look up at that horn that clackson
and I thought if that son of a [__]
goes off
uh the thing is that there they didn't
mess around with that it was either all
out go
we're not go there wasn't any in between
a drill or anything like that no there
was no well we'll drop a bomb and scare
you or something like that there wasn't
any of that commitment and the whole
thing was coordinated from NATO
to nuclear artillery right next to the
female right next to the Iron Curtain
and then as we're rolling stuff back and
then the B-52s you know they would come
in for deeper penetration
and it was all go and if they
I looked up there if that horn went off
I thought [__] you know there's no way
to get back either you know it's all
[__] that you can come back but what
am I going to come back to yeah and you
knew you know that right I mean you know
if you launch on that thing it's well
that's the end of the world like when we
were in England sitting alert we were a
nuclear delivery thing we had 12 active
uh lines 12 there in England
when we were home for that 30 days
and you know that if this thing started
that that's a primary target
and there's probably only 12 guys if
this thing ever kicked off there's going
to be 12 individuals at Lake and Heath
Air Base that are going to be alive
everybody else is going to be dying so
you take off with an armed thermonuclear
weapon and in your rearview mirror
everything that you know and love your
family your friends everything
disappears in a nuclear cloud
and you often wonder
I got that son of a [__] it's in my
center line pylon and I'm really pissed
off
so we thought well we'd go upwind and
bail out over some Norwegian Fjord and
climb in a cave and wait
until all the radiation went away or
whatever you can visualize or something
like that however I lost more com I lost
more comrades in the Cold War than I did
than the Vietnam War from accidents
training accidents
or from what
well a lot of it was highly classified
the Gary Powers thing the reconnaissance
and the RB the rb-47s did and there was
a lot of other clandestine things that
even today they know nothing about now
there's a lot of memorials this is one
thing it's my pet peeve right now is
that there's Korea all the wars
everybody has a monument there on the
mall
there's no Monument about the Cold War
and uh
of course there wasn't any battle line
and there wasn't any casualty report and
stuff on it was all classified and stuff
and we won that damn thing we really did
we won it
and I can always say that I got shot
down twice once in the Cold War
the one that mattered and then the
Vietnam War
yeah because you had another ejection
right what happened on that injection
uh
well the saying was you know what
happens if you have a nuclear weapon on
your aircraft and you eject or you
wouldn't would you never fly with a nuke
a live nuke no they would never I don't
uh the Tactical Air Command the
Strategic Air Command B-52 Chrome domes
I think they did fly
with uh with fully armed nukes ready to
go and I think they quit that after they
dropped a couple of them inadvertently
when
anyway that was an embarrassing thing uh
during my time we never flew it and we
flew with the dummies that we'd go out
and drop them on the Range
uh
you know to see the accuracy
but if you're dropping a really powerful
bomb
the only thing we would do we'd ride on
the side
of the bomb in grease pencil
something like
I don't know who the who the Soviet
premiers were whatever
because there was one one thing you come
500 knots right on the deck at 50 feet
and you pickle it off and then you try
to keep going and getting away as far as
you can
and you put the thing on the side and it
said well he says well Uncle ho wasn't
to put an uncle ho what the hell was it
whatever the Soviet thing was he says
you got three choices
you can either run for 37 seconds or you
can dig for 37 seconds
and the third choice is you can do any
combination of either one you want
it's kind of sick sick humor right here
so what was how do you eject again well
I was on a test hop
uh
actually in England I got kind of tired
of going out to what we call the marsh
Gunnery Range and dropping little bdu-33
blue bombs practicing and I wanted
something a little because I was a
maintenance guy I had an A P license and
unlike maintenance and so I was going to
go over and do the chief of quality
control flight test maintenance officer
which is really a neat job
because we got to fly the airplanes
without the pylons and without the drop
tanks and they were clean and they were
really a lot of fun to fly
and the missions were short and very
demanding
and uh
the one problem one thing if you're a
wing commander and you want to get fired
those we call them Victor lines Victor
alert lines and whether they're in
commission or not is very important
and if the wing Commander wants to get
fired he's all he has to do is drop one
of those lines because the maintenance
or some other thing
because when they check in every morning
down at whatever headquarters all of his
nukes are ready to go and the pilots are
briefed
and then all of a sudden there wasn't
now the weather in England was really
dog [__] A lot of times it was supposed
to have VFR 500 and 5 000 overcasts and
five miles disability
but it came up that there was a lot of a
lot of Maintenance and the airplanes
were coming out of Maintenance and they
were backed up because they couldn't get
flight tests and so it came to the point
one day that we were going to lose one
of those new clients bad thing that was
really bad
and so
all the you know in England I think it
was I think it was like 600 foot
overcast and drizzle and maybe two or
three miles visibility
and uh the vice Wing Commander Colonel
Hurd he come to me and he says hey dick
I know the weather's really bad but God
damn we need this we need this thing to
replace it you know that or are we going
to lose one of the Victor lines and of
course hell I'm a combat guy I've said I
can do anything see go get them
and so so I tax you out
and light the burner and go down the
runway pull the nose up now it's really
a fun fun thing because you can run in
full afterburner a full After Burner
climb with an airplane without all the
Ordnance on it boy it's really it's
really a Sparky little airplane and it's
an afterburner climb to 40 000 feet and
I break out on top over the Norse say at
about 42 000 feet I can see
so we have weather from forty thousand
feet all the way to 600 feet home and
one of the tests is a negative z-check
uh and that's where you some guys were
all inverted I just pull up and then
push it over to
negative G and all this stuff floats up
and in the F-100 uh the canopy was
designed in such an area now there's
always dirt and crud and
screwdrivers and nuts and bolts and crap
and it all ends up right over your head
but just behind your head and when you
come back to positive G
that it all falls and it falls they
gather it all a very cleverly
the way the physics of the airplane is
and it goes right down the back of your
neck
happens every time so I always had a
collection of screwdrivers and wrenches
and stuff I found in a cockpit and I'd
put it on the board and say anybody any
mechanic up there that would like to get
it they can you know they can come and
claim their Ranch of course nobody ever
claimed it and stuff
so I did one
I did one of those and when I came back
to positive G I felt a horrible clunk
I mean a major clunk just like the
engine was loose or something
and I thought God what the hell is that
and so this time I don't got a lot more
speed pull the nose up really heavy and
really jammed the stick forward and sure
enough there was another big shift of
weight it seems like right behind me
only this time when I came back to
positive G the 42 PSI normal operating
position of the oil pressure went from
there to zero
in a bat of an eye clunk
so now
had this big huge clunk like the engine
was loose and I thought well maybe it
pulled a wire loose
because the engine was running fine
but it had zero oil pressure another
thing too if usually if you have a
broken oil line you know the it'll the
oil pressure will just kind of kind of
bounce around a little bit and slowly
Decay but but to go to absolute zero and
it's breaking it at the bottom of the
night just bang zero and that's not
normal
and of course you want to think it's uh
you want to think it's not real serious
because where you are and you finally
think I'm out over the North Sea
there's weather all the way
600 feet at home
and uh
I says okay so I practice
uh I'd say I have to call a Mayday okay
mayday mayday mayday uh it's a ring Dove
two one that's call sign bring it up two
one mayday mayday mayday where I am and
what my problem is
so I practiced a couple of times so I
can get my really cool Chuck Yeager
voice
and it took a while too because the
first time I tried it in my headset it
didn't sound very good so I got it
really cool
and one of the procedures is if you have
zero oil pressure you don't want to jock
it the engine back and forth right you
want to set the power
and that means it'll it'll run longer so
I knew that I needed about 83 percent on
Final Approach and an extra 20 knots to
get level because the F-100 did not have
a zero zero seat
uh I think it was but you had to get
level if you were descending you had no
chance of making it
okay and that extra 20 knots would get
your level okay half laps 83 and start
down into the Merc
and they had to Vector me around a
little bit for identification back in
those days anyway it took an extended
period of time
and I was telling them I finally got on
the GCA controller
and it says look give me uh
transmission breaks you know tell me
you're on glide path turn left whatever
the the dialogue is but give me
transmission break so in case something
happens you know that I can call you
of course the GCA controllers
they when they start giving the
instructions they just clamp down on the
and the transmitter and so therefore
nobody heard anything at home when I was
on Final Approach anyway kind of got a
short position I was really proud of
myself I finally intercept Glide path I
lowered the nose
lowered the nose a half lapse had to
gear down and hey 83 percent was perfect
they never ejected the engine at all
this is really cool
and I'm coming down and they're giving
me the dialogue about left and right on
glide path and so forth
and it just started to break out I
couldn't see the runway but I could
start to see down you know a little bit
and uh
and I was thinking about well I'm
rolling out on the runway and how am I
going to write this thing up and
so forth
so then there was a grinding noise
uh the intensity grew more and more
and and then it was it grew louder and
louder and louder and then there was a
huge explosion that the compressor
stalls and when the compressor stalls
then it shoots fire out both ends of the
airplane so there's this grinding and
this huge bang and fire shooting out in
the front and dirt comes up in your face
and now I'm looking for that I call it
the small corner of time
there's a small Corner time from here
just a couple of seconds that corner of
time I can survive and if I'm outside of
that the ejection won't work I mean I'll
hit the ground before
and so they use every bit of that that
extra 20 knots that you have on board to
level off and eject and maybe
that that the parachute will open in
time
and so I did and I leveled off
but then I looked down and there was a
little town called Brandon right on the
Final Approach and I could see that I
could see the town right in front of me
and I knew that if I banked the airplane
that it would probably just bank and
then write itself and still go into the
town so this happened in just a couple
of seconds I'm slowing down I'm coming
back on the stick to slow down to get in
that small corner of time and I trim it
got the left trim going and reached down
with my left hand and grabbed the handle
and pull it up
whoops and pull it up and it blew the
canopy off and then immediately squeeze
both triggers
and knowing where that jet is going to
be in a Hound fit and a handful of time
that is the most wonderful smoothest
experience you'll ever have is that
right up and out of that thing but the
time compression is really interesting
because as it as the airplane was going
up it was going up the rails I thought
there's going to be an accident board
and they're going to go through all the
paperwork and I'm going to have to
remember what I did for the last three
days what I drank and I'm thinking about
all that stuff going up the ejection
rails and then I thought my God
I had to put the Colonel's name on there
and it's heard Colonel heard is it
h-e-r-d or I must you know I misspelled
it and I thought God everybody in the
whole world is going to see that thing
and on this paper that you know the
flight plan or the Clarence thing and I
misspelled the guy's name how horrible
that's all going through your mind
saying it's still going up to the rails
and then uh the parachute opens
and uh you know you can feel it
uh as the canopy starts to open all the
all the shrine not the Shroud line but
um
yeah the right not the risers but the
Shroud lines are all in there in their
bundle and you can feel them coming off
your back see
and then it opened
and then it was then it's opened and it
happened so quick I looked straight
between my legs expecting this to look
down right into the cockpit of course
that was ridiculous
and I looked around and off my left
shoulder
I could see the airplane and airplanes
flying along and now I'm low enough I
can see the runway and for all the work
the airplane was gonna freaking land on
the runway
I thought boy they could have were they
going to get I'm going to get from that
for this you know jumping out of a
perfectly good airplane it lands on The
Runaway and they did it
and then the next thing I know I'm in
the trees
a parachute comes down through the trees
uh if you're going to bail out pine
trees are very nice kind of smaller
Pines because you know their interlacing
you come down through them and they Bend
just right and by the time I got to the
surface I ended up stopping about an
inch or two above the beautiful pine
floor and then with another Shake then
the parachute canopy came down you know
around like that
okay now I'm right out of Vietnam see
and I've ejected
and uh you're in the ene trend for a
whole year I've been training for escape
and evasion height to parachute you know
get the radio get that damn beeper off
which didn't work this time either the
parachute uh beeper and I got to get the
radio out but in in England we don't
have the double radios and stuff and so
right over there there was a guy an
English guy in a coating time he was out
trimming the Queen's forest and his eyes
were about bigger saucers and he's
looking you know his eyes open of course
I come down and we're nuclear alert and
I have a go of visor on so here this guy
comes crashing down through the trees
and he said he heard heard the explosion
he heard the seat come down and the
canopy come down and then this guy
spacecraft with the golden helmet come
down right in front of him basically
and uh
and it's starting to back away I said no
no I need your help I need your help
and uh
yeah come on then I took the helmet off
and then I thought God I got to call
somebody you know my radios are don't
normally in my vest in Vietnam but now
they're in the damn seat kit one radio
in the seat kit so another way to get to
it
is to pull that handle on your on your
seat c-kit that you sit on it's got your
rafting survival gear and stuff in there
so I pull the handle and a CO2 cartridge
comes off and this yellow RAF ex you
know emerges I've been making all this
goddamn noise right in front of this guy
and he turns around and starts running
around
where'd the plane hit uh they are
playing their plane came and it started
a very left turn and it just missed the
town it hit right beside Brandon
right across the road it didn't hurt
anybody but it uh it you know the
typical Fireball and stuff that comes
down and as I was pulling back I says it
just blew and I'm getting out now nobody
heard me
now the colonel that was coming back
from across country he heard me
he's the only one that heard Mike my
call
and uh
so so anyway I took the Helen off and I
ran and got him and I said hey I need
your help and it brought him back
and uh
what the hell oh yeah then I got down to
the kit and opened it up and found the
radio and opened it up and turned it on
and I called
uh
I made a radio call and for the time
that it blew up it was only about 93
seconds that whole time
that happened
okay now I got a really good drinking
buddy and he is the uh the Airfield he's
the Airfield uh
uh support helicopter and it's a it's
called Pedro and Pedro is uh hh-43 and
has intermission rotors and their whole
mission is to uh they have the Sputnik
that hangs it's a you know it's a big
ball firefighting stuff it's about as
big as the stable it's just it's a
sphere
and the fire this whole thing is set up
so the firefighters and their and their
uh aluminum suits and there's a
big Fireball and burning and the pilots
inside they got to go rescue them so the
rotor horse pushes it away and they take
this Sputnik with their fire fighting
thing and they fight their way through
the flames and they get in the cockpit
and they and they pull the pilot out
that's their whole thing
and so
now I didn't know about this but
nobody heard me say that I was getting
out and the end of the runway the mobile
controller
his name was Jeffco yeah
in fact he was a prisoner of war
I think he was I could be wrong about
that but anyway he said he's a mobile
controller and so he starts screaming on
the radio he says get out there quick no
shoot no shoot there's no shoot I didn't
see a shoot get out there quick
and he's screaming at the Pedro and so
the guy lifts off and he's he's in the
helicopter and he's heading for the
fireball out there it's going out
and he keeps saying now the only thing
that he saw was a landing light came out
of the weather and crashed into a big
firewall
solved so the guy my buddy and the Pedro
helicopter he's he's out there he's
going the guy's screaming at him to get
out there quick and so he's going fast
and for some reason he thought he could
get there quicker if he pickled off that
foot Nick that he's hanging below it so
he pickled it off see
crashed halfway to the wreck site
and so
he's coming around he's circling the
wreck side it's all you see is a big uh
you know typical crash site but
debris and Fireball and stuff
and he's thinking oh [__] you know
that's Rutan out there it's my best
friend it's really terrible and then he
gets out there in a minute and 93
seconds or something I call him on the
radio
I says hey
I'm down come and get me come and get me
and so now his first thought he's
circling this Fireball
and he thinks that I'm in there right
calling for help and I call him and I
says get your ass out here and get me
and then his whole thing his whole
training everything he's trained up for
was that Sputnik thing and there's the
fire in a classic situation and they're
going to land and and push the fire out
of the way but he pickled it off and
it's not there oops and he's heart sick
he says my god I've screwed up now
rutan's gonna burn alive down there and
I could have saved him that's really bad
and then he thinks and then he then he
then he starts to realize wait a minute
there's no [__] way that that that's
alive in that night down there
and so he calls and he says he says
then he called my name he says dick is
that you I says yeah I get your ass out
here and get me
you know thinking of Vietnam I need to
get rescued really quick
and then and it's really interesting
this plaintiff voice that he said
he says where are you I says I bail out
about a mile short he says
you bailed out you ejected
and then you can understand the
metamorphosis of emotion that he's going
through God from the guy that's burning
down there and I just jettisoned my
firefighting equipment and now he's
burning and he's calling me and I can't
get to him
and then the adulation of feeling or we
bail out and he's okay
and I says yeah get your ass out here
and get me
and so then he did come out and get me
of course here you bailed out see and uh
so there's the Officers Club you got to
tell the story about everything
in my
squadron commander Jake Engel he comes
up and he says hey
he says tell me I got a couple of
questions he says what were the
indications you know did the you know
what uh we have a panel full of a lot of
a lot of faults and a big Master caution
light comes on and
and he says he says well which one of
those lights came on you know
you know thought
kidding me the only the only answer was
that big red Master caution light that
was accentuated and confirmed by the
fact that there was a grinding noise
and fire shot out the front
and then that's all I remember Jake
and then I kept thinking about seeing
that airplane flying off
it was a big pole sticking out of the
canopy and I could see it and I could
see the runway now
and that horrible feeling
and so I couldn't sleep that night so
about three o'clock in the morning I
called maintenance control it says hey
uh you guys got the engine yet
and he says yeah they just brought it in
and uh it's in Hangar so and so it's on
a dolly you know you can go and look at
it if you want to
in a jet engines it usually crushes part
of the intake or the you know the
compressor blades that spin as they're
spinning they can tell what the RPM was
that they crush and then they're bent
back and they can have a pretty good
idea of what the power of the engine was
and so it was really eerie and I got in
the car and I went down there to Mission
Control there's nobody on the field it
was kind of drizzly you know and there's
there's the hair so I drive up open the
door
and sure enough I look over there
and there's the engine it's on an engine
stand and the excuse me the top of the
fuselage is still there and then the
tail is all burnt
and whatever
so I walk over there
up to the engine by the side see
and uh
and I know and I know they can tell the
power on the engine by the bent blades
and there's the the face of it all you
do is walk around walk around and look
at that so I stopped there for a little
bit and you safely or you have a
horrible accident rate for some for some
reason
a lot of accidents and stuff or the
whole F-100 engine was it had problems
with it and
and uh so I thought boy they're going to
hang me for this you know the first
thing they do on an accident rate is
they blame the pilots it was pilot air
everything
and I took a deep breath and I thought
I'm going to walk around and look at the
front of this engine on the intake and
then I'll know
and uh that may be the end of my flying
you know my career I jumped out of a
perfectly good airplane
so I went around and looked at the face
of the engine
in the blades it crushed the intake into
a kind of a d section
so all the blades were straight and the
ones that were which crushed the uh the
blades that weren't rotating like that
they were crushed straight in like that
zero power zero RPM zero RPM at impact
and I thought God
you know maybe there was something wrong
with the engine
and with that I went back and had a good
night's sleep
so you end up I mean uh you know doing
other jobs in the in the Air Force
um uh like you already talked about you
went and he had to go and get your
degree since you didn't have a college
degree yeah
eventually you you retire from the Air
Force
um and then what it what after you
retired from the Air Force and I guess
even as you were even before you retired
for the Air Force you were kind of doing
some stuff with your brother you were
starting this kind of crazy test pilot
you were flying these little homemade
planes that your brother was making
threw a couple of those before I retired
but then the retirement thing
was uh
had a big problem
with the Air Force at this time and uh
it was in the 70s and the military at
least the Air Force was permeated with
drugs all kinds of drug problems and
stuff
and uh
so
Hosmer the wing Commander says hey dick
go down and take over the field
maintenance thing you're a maintenance
guy
and you know make your squadron
commander of a maintenance Squadron
so I got 420 maintenance people
and we do engine overhauls and break
over hauls and stuff not crew chief
stuff but just kind of fuel maintenance
thing
and it was impermeated with drugs
a lot of drugs but the people
and it I never was a smoker
and I knew that smoking was bad for
everybody
for anybody
and uh
and it was it was there was one guy we
were an anti-smoking scene maybe that
was kind of unique because everything
was built around cigarettes and alcohol
the social environment there was one guy
his name was Al Munch and he was smoking
all the time and we're at the in the
club and they were talking and arguing
and
typical Friday night BS and I says Al
look at that it says look at the
cigarettes uh you know it's got you
he said nah I could give it up anytime
we have a big argument you know I said
I'll tell you what I said here's here's
five ten here's a ten dollar bill I put
it down on the table it says you can't
go 20 minutes without a cigarette oh
yeah oh confidence
and so and I knew he couldn't because
he's addicted
anyway he was a big addict for nicotine
and it wasn't more than six or eight
minutes later that he came back he had a
whole lung full of smoke and he blew it
in my face and he took the five dollar
bill and he threw it on the ground
so anyway I had a maintenance water
and I said there's going to be no
smoking in my orderly room or any of the
buildings well that didn't go over too
well with a lot of people
and another thing I had a third of my
third of my troops were female
maintenance people really good
and uh
but they would lock them up and the wife
the wife Barracks at night and they had
you know some big WAFF Sergeant would
control the WAFF oh women in the Air
Force okay yeah that's right women in
the Air Force
anyway there was a big sergeant that
would control all these women and they'd
lock them up at night
and my my other squatter and he had all
the crew chiefs and they would stake in
and play with my play with my wife you
know get in trouble and he get caught
playing with him inside sneaking in
and uh
so that the Jag and I had court martial
Authority
and we were doing a lot of drug stuff
people really hung out in drugs even had
a couple of general court martials guys
trying to torch the building and
sabotage my car and attacked me with
Kung Fu darts it was just really a mess
and a lot of marijuana
so
uh and I says look I want it says why in
the world you're going to lock up a
third of my troops females and all the
guys they can run around downtown and
raise hell but they have to stay in this
white Barracks I said that's that says
look I'm the commander they're my people
and I want them all in my barracks
and they would say colonel Rattan do you
have any idea what would happen if we
put females in the barracks I says yeah
I know exactly what would happen in
about 10 days it would sort itself out
and we'd be back to normal and they
could have all the rights and Liberties
that all the guys have yeah I'll put one
corner downstairs that'd be the wife
ended yeah dude oh no man they wouldn't
got to do that at all
uh well the no smoking thing and trying
to lock unlock my wife at night
uh
then I was throwing kids out of the Air
Force for doing drugs boy there's some
horrible stuff that was happening to
these kids
but then what would bother me is I'd go
I'd go to the Commander's reception
sometime you know the wing Commander
he'd have the other officers into his
and I'd look out in the back at these
receptions and the wives would be out
there talking you know they'd be smoking
marijuana and I thought I'm throwing
kids out of the Air Force for what the
laughs are doing back there
and I looked around at the whole Saint
now I had a great combat record I had
all my uh
military training command and staff done
all this thing I was on my way to be
chief of staff
and I thought
you know it happened just like that
uh
I turned around
and I went over to this
orderly room or whatever the thing was
cbpo
and I says I'm going home
and I had 20 years in a microsecond
just enough for the retirement
and that was another area of something
that I just wasn't ready for the
politics of that
uh
so then it went out and got a hold of my
brother and we flew around the world
[Laughter]
yeah and that that uh that story is uh
you know a crazy story of you know as
you're going through this thing as
you're as you uh you know get together
the money and speaking of cigarettes you
know you at one point you get a tobacco
company that's going to sponsor the
whole thing you won't take their money
uh so you scrap this thing together you
know you were talking earlier about the
Voyager aircraft itself and this is cool
because I remember it Dave remembers it
Dave probably remembers it better than I
did because he was a little uh uh
aircraft addict like you were me I just
thought it was cool but the whole thing
weighed like you know 500 pounds or
something like this and
and you guys took this thing you fly
this thing around the world you got
incredible details of that inside this
book um you know sleep deprivation it's
not what nine days it took you to do
this
uh you get done with that
um you do you run for Congress out here
in California you got all kinds of stuff
in this book you you set a bunch of
Records
um
tried to go around the world again in a
balloon that was interesting
well I thought you know here I am
successful around the world and in
airplanes you don't have to do something
like that you're looking for you know uh
what else can I do what else is out
there has anybody gone around the world
in a balloon non-stop you end up saved
by a parachute again yep that's right a
bail out of that thing
only this time it was fully funded so I
got Baron Hilton and Pepsi sponsors I
got a million and a half dollars and
built this pressurized capsule that was
pressurized I could stay in the
stratosphere even sit on the moon
uh close the loop life support system
the radios we launched out of
Albuquerque about
well we had about a three hour delay on
the launch which saved our lives really
and they launched this Baron Hilton cut
the thing and sirens and patriotic music
and we launched off we're on our way
around the world
anyway at thirty thousand feet uh
to do a design screw up by the
manufacturer the balloon wouldn't vent
so as it started to heat and expand it
wouldn't vent so it actually ruptured
the balloon the helium envelope blew the
whole bottom of it out
of course
uh biggest a lot of big explosion but
it's enough to bounce this off the floor
when that thing let go
and now we're coming down
and we launched out
to fly around the world and didn't even
get out of the county
that's an opportunity for character
development
uh I ended up in a choya cactus patch
guy says well what are you going to do
next I says well this is the first day
of our second attempt
but anyway since there's only one first
nobody gives a crap about who does
anything second
a guy a Swiss watch company
uh
God I don't want to say the wrong I
think it was Breitling
the Breitling Orbiter
they took off in an incredible flight
attendant Jones and perchon Picard neat
guy
and I sat there and watched them
and I even made the comment in public
that it was all it's very nice to be in
competition with those who have
absolutely no chance of success whoops
so I don't know my co-pilot he was not
totally honest with me about parachutes
and uh
now real strong winds on the ground like
40 mile an hour winds and a parachute
and if you don't do everything exactly
right you're going to get hurt really
bad
and unfortunately
he wasn't truthful with me about his
parachute experience and so
uh he jumped out first and got a good
shoot but without knowing how to handle
the high Wing Landing
parachutes are neat they'll save you
life in flight but it'll kill you on the
ground by being drug across the desert
and I ended up
I landed really you know it's you know
trying to step off your car at 40 miles
an hour your feet hitting it really
flips you around
anyway he didn't know anything about
that he landed backwards and he got some
severe injuries
and I landed
properly
going backwards and my helmet hit the
ground so hard I thought it was going to
break and by the time I got both of
those things jettisoned I was in a
choice a cactus patch
you know the jumping cactus a little
needle gloves
and I was looking through my
you know look looking through this
cactus in my face at our million dollar
balloon
of course it would hit and and knock off
some of the propane tanks and go back up
again and hit again and
it discharge different stuff and finally
hit a power line in Texas oh and it
burned to the ground
well that one burned to ground I mean
but you had already uh made it as the
first person around the world without
stopping or refueling right with the
with the Voyager which is an awesome
story inside this book
um and you know you've talked a little
bit about earlier on the podcast but to
get the full story the book lays it out
all kinds of issues you overcame
um just just just an incredible story
and uh you know well one of the many
reasons you were inducted into the
aviation Hall of Fame yep
um and uh I mean this the stories in the
book they're just incredible
um if if you're listening
definitely just just order this book and
uh you know I I
we've been talking for a pretty long
time now I don't wanna I don't wanna I
don't want to take up you know forever
um but uh but Dave what do you got you
got any questions
I got all sorts of questions but I
mostly just enjoyed listening
um
I'm you know we're three and a half
hours into this almost and I'm just just
captivated hearing the stories and and I
I routinely get to say this because I
get to sit off over here off to the side
when when Jocko does these podcasts and
I just get to watch people have these
conversations but
the aviation conversations are are
unique and they're special to me because
I could picture a lot of the things
you're talking about I can picture the
way you're describing them
but on uh unrelated to that I've been
sitting here thinking this whole time
about a saying that and I think it's
it's some phrase that says don't meet
your Heroes something like that which I
think is like a some catchphrase that
says like well don't meet your Heroes
because when you meet them you're going
to be disappointed because you've
created this image you've had of them in
your mind well I've gotten to meet
several of my heroes and never once
never once have I been disappointed
but what's unique about this for me sir
is that
all the other people I've ever met I can
only read about them in books and and
hear about the things that they've done
but I know you because I got to see what
you did I was old enough and we were
modern enough that what you did in that
airplane in 1986 and I can vividly
remember the three Loops you did over
Mojave when you landed and getting I can
picture that as a as a teenager already
captive captivated by airplanes so to
get to sit here with you
knowing who you are not from books but
from actually seeing it happen live and
in person this is just an absolute
remarkable day for me so I can't thank
you enough for letting me be part of
this this has been this has been awesome
I am I'm honored to have met one of my
heroes today thank you very much this uh
my brother come up and he says with the
Advent and availability
of uh
every room
it reminds me of an opportunity I had to
meet the king the now King of England
foreign
but anyway what happened when you met
the king of England well I called him
hey Chuck and I didn't go over too well
he's a fellow fighter pilot I didn't
wrote about Americans don't bow down to
royalty in any case of an American
hey Chuck well anyway
uh well the The Bert said that with the
availability of carbon fiber he thinks
it's possible to build an airplane light
enough that'll carry enough fuel to go
around the world
now the airplane took off these are
round numbers uh 10 000 pounds 3.6 tons
of Aviation gas
3.6 tons
the the carbon fiber structure weighed
926 pounds
in a wing span bigger than a Boeing 737
and a cockpit half the size of one of
the restrooms
but all of that that 926 pounds had to
carry 3.6 tons of fuel two engines
avionics radios two hearty Souls little
food and water
and uh
and launch off I I it's one of those
things that you get on a train one day
and you realize
the Train's going off a cliff and it's
too late you can't get off
uh you know what five and a half years
I've told everybody hey we're going to
fly around the world help us out had no
money volunteers
uh begged and borrowed quarter million
dollars worth of carbon fiber
uh half a million dollars worth of
avionics and Radars back in those old
days with no GPS and so forth
a mission control system and set that
whole thing up and I describe it in the
book The the first the first part of the
the next five minutes and and I named
the book because how many times in my
life have I sat in a cockpit and
wondered what the next five minutes of
my life is going to be like and there
have been a number of places and I
haven't we haven't even talked about
some of the flight test stuff that we
did with Bert's airplanes
but the book starts with uh
trying to put
put the thing in perspective what did it
feel like
when I first started going out and
giving my talks my wife when I met her
after after the flight she listened to a
couple of my
lectures and I'm kind of a technical
person
and I think it's important that my
audience knows how many fuel tanks we
had and how we sequenced them and and
and how the L over D and all that other
stuff and finally she come up to me and
she says dick
she says nobody gives a Frick about how
many fuel tanks he said I want you to
tell them what it felt like
and so I changed the whole tenor of the
book and it wasn't the book's not
written for Aviation as you can tell it
was written for to try to to try to talk
about uh challenges and motivation and
uh and some of the emotional challenge
that we had along the way
try to set that up and the book the book
starts with
I'm sitting in the end of the runway at
Edwards Air Force Base that morning
we had
roughly 25 percent more fuel than we'd
ever had on board before much less
flight tested
uh the airplane was uh of course there
wasn't much to it so it's pretty
flexible and it could Bend
and I'm sitting there thinking uh
because the two and a half years of
flight tests and the 69 flights
we had some horrible emergencies uh many
many may days the propeller blade came
off and it ripped the engine off it was
just hanging in the bottom of the
cowling
and flight control problems and ran into
some rain and almost uh
one of the airfoils on the airplane
didn't like rain and we found out about
it the hard way and we just barely flew
out of the rain in time to save I mean
it was numerous stories about that it's
in the book
but try to to try to
to set up the situation that I'm sitting
at the end of the runway what am I
thinking about what's going to happen
trying to remember some of the stuff
that's happened ahead at the time
and uh
uh another thing it's you know people
are really interested in interpersonal
relationships
uh I met I met uh
I separated from my first wife and later
on I met another girl her name is Gina
Gina Jaeger
and we had a big and romantic thing and
about the time we met Bert says hey how
about doing this around the world thanks
wow okay
you designed it and Gene and I will fly
this thing around the world see we're
off on this five-year Odyssey this
romantic artist and it was really good I
mean some of the most interesting times
in my life
but then for some reason she decided to
uh
well she got out of she got out of the
bed and went into the other bedroom
and I didn't have enough time to replace
her
and there was a whole bunch of pressure
going on so all of a sudden we're
we're have this
romance ended and we weren't even
talking to each other and now we've got
to go and fly around the world together
and the fact is that it takes two pilots
to do that
you know you take turns but she couldn't
fly the airplane
she didn't want to learn how to operate
in any of the systems I kept saying damn
it
I can't do this thing by myself I need
to have another pilot you need to burn
this but she wouldn't and I says if you
don't learn how to run and set up the
nav systems and all the other
complicated things about this airplane
I'm going to replace you with an actual
pilot
and she looked at me and says either
take me or I'll burn the airplane
so my choices were two and one of them
would have been in jail
and so when we the two of us climbed
into that airplane that day that morning
at Edwards Air Force Base
I had no idea how we were going to do
this I
know that what did you think your
percentage chance of a success was well
none I was it was all set up it was to
go
it didn't have enough time to fix any of
these things
the weatherman came up one day and he
says
you know we've been working really hard
on this thing to get all the systems the
mission control the weather the
communication systems the worldwide all
this stuff had to be set up and it says
I
and the weather was terrible
and uh we had missed the weather window
and it was in December and it was
outside of the other one and the weather
guy Len Selman comes up and he says hey
dick he says well we missed the weather
window we have to wait till next year
and I said
that's all the other stuff that were
borrowed all these can all these big
huge computers and communication system
are all borrowed and I didn't know if I
could get the uh the all that equipment
back in a year and all the people back
in a year and I looked at him and I said
Lynn
I said the airplane's not ready yet it's
close
he says
linear plane is finally ready I'm going
to walk outside it's a metaphor so I'm
going to walk outside
and if it's raining I'll wait and if
it's not raining then I'm going to go I
said you go back in your weather thing
and you find me your way around the
world outside of the weather window
and next day comes back and says hey
dick I think I found you away except for
one thing can't get you across Africa
I and the man looked at the world map
the big one maps and Africa is only this
bit
worry about that when we get there
profound as you see in the movie
uh
so anyway I wanted I wanted to to rest
when the airplane is finally ready and
all the people sign off not
metaphorically they they say that it's
ready the engines the systems everything
is ready to go
you know the refueling and Bowsers are
already at Edwards Air Force Base the
Press has been notified
and I thought
when that's done Gina and I we can go up
in the Sierras and just rest needed to
have some rest you know just
be ready
and when it was finally ready the next
morning we had a weather briefing that
was either go or no go at 10 o'clock
and I walked into the weather briefing
and
Lynn Stillman the weather guy comes in
and he's smiling and I thought oh shoot
and he's telling me but during the
briefing I realized that he that the
weather is perfect for departure
except for Africa
and I thought
I would just you know just one day off
they could just go and get my head clear
one day is all I wanted but there wasn't
and it's just like
just like General Eisenhower when it was
gone D-Day they all looked at him and
said he had to say go or no go
and uh it says okay let's go and then
in 10 seconds I was alone in the room
everybody left
you know it's all choreographed where
the engine starts take it over there set
it up at Edwards Air Force Base the fuel
Bowsers and we had the last the last
supper with the family
uh
then I thought that here I am I should
have the VIP quarters
the VIP quarters out there at Edwards
that I didn't check on and I trusted
somebody else to do that well they
didn't they didn't know anything about
it
and so I ended up in a real old Barracks
kind of a just one step up from an open
Bay barracks
and
those things they have Central Heating
and the Ducks whistle and they make a
lot of noise
and this I go in this room and it's bare
and it's an old military bid with you
know the steel thing on it
and it's just a terrible thing I think
God no I asked the driver I says well
hey there's the VIP quarters over there
you know here I'm going to fly around
the world at least somebody he says that
he didn't even know anything about that
[Music]
so I'm laying in there and listening to
that and of course you know it's uh
wake up in a handful of hours
and I'm laying there and it's hot and
I'm trying to get some sleep and all
sudden there's a knock on the door
I thought
no is this
so I'm really pissed I get up open the
door and I flight surgeon Dr George
julen is there he's our flight guy
for all of her medical stuff
and I said George
what are you doing and he says oh dick I
forgot
and he had a little box
you know like the children's milk
cartons you know they're open them up
and stuff he says I want a urine sample
when you wake up
uh and here's the box that I wanted I
want you to do it
and
I thought George you woke me up you woke
me up to give me a box of piss in
and then I was really pissed I was I was
so keyed up about that I don't think I
slept in the front of the wake up time
column and we went out and called in the
board the airplane with no no sleep per
se in a car and a co-pilot that wasn't
talking to me and didn't know how to do
running any of the systems and we took
off having no idea how in the hell I was
going to do this
and uh we thought about all the stuff
we'd gone through in the last five and a
half years
and then it was time and I thought you
know dick you're probably going to be
dead in the next five minutes what you
really ought to do right now
is uh shut the engine down
and open the little canopy and get out
and walk out of the desert at least
you'll be alive tomorrow and then I
thought wait a minute
I ask all these people all these years
to come and help me
and a lot of them sacrifice quite a bit
some of them even lost their jobs to
come and help
had I done that they would have had
every right to chase me down
and commit premature euthanasia for some
damn coward that totally deserved it
so I said there's no way out there's no
way
so that morning
trepidation that pushed both the
throttles wide open released a little
tiny break like a foot on a nose wheel
or something foot on a skateboard
because brakes are really heavy so we
didn't take any breaks
and that thing lumbered down the runway
and uh
it accelerated yeah there was a
acceleration checkpoint
and I I asked I put more fuel on board
the airplane than what the designer
wanted
and he was really mad about that
but I was worried about running out of
fuel I always had this nightmare that
run out of fuel 100 miles short
hell of a record but we still failed on
first around the world
so I put up some flag markers down the
runway and he says dick you need to have
this specific air speed as you cross
each one of the markers and because you
don't have really have wheel brakes on
the airplane and
to be able to stop before you run out in
Edwards dry lake you need to have
these Target air speeds as you cross
them
well he didn't know it but dick was
really tired he had been at this thing
five and a half years then all this
emotional things with my girlfriend
plus all the other things that we had to
deal with the only thing I wanted I just
wanted this freaking thing over with and
I didn't care if I was on fire I wasn't
going to quit so I had to give him a
Blood Oath to my brother okay I'll do
that I promise promise no one full will
there's no freaking way I'm gonna quit I
want it over with I just you get to that
point
and so we started accelerating this as
the flag markers came by we were
starting to can you know one not low two
knots three knots and at Midfield
the last marker
we needed uh
86 knots yeah 100 knots for takeoff 86
knots
and I was four knots low
so I keyed the mic button that says
we're four knots low at the Midfield
and nobody said anything I think
everybody knew there was no freaking way
I was going to quit besides that the
airspeed indicators over here see and
here's here's 65 it only had to go a
little bit farther to 100 a little bit
more just a little bit more
that's this is all I have to and I look
down at the end of the runway it's still
a mile and a mile and a half away I said
shoot there's no problem not knowing
that the faster you go the more rapid
you consume the runway
and uh
so we hit our rotation speed and I gave
it three more knots from Mom
and the wingtips were dragging on the
runway
and I reached out and grabbed that
control stick and it says well dick if
you'd never been smooth at any time in
your life you better be smooth now
because this is the big one
and it reached down there and started
pulling back on the stick and the Canard
lifted and the boom tank started coming
up and I could see the Wings come up
slowly slowly slowly and I swear to God
they were going to touch over my head
and with 95 percent of that world's
longest runway it lifted off
and
actually I have the video if you want to
look at it or see it or include it but
the wings came up real slow
and it lifted off and it flew in ground
effect and it finally got to 100 knots
and if it got to 100 knots we had enough
power to climb
and so we shook off the wingtips which
were damaged lost three foot of wingspan
and they were talking about a boarding
this is
there ain't no fine way I'm going to
quit they're just not going to quit
under any circumstances I don't care
what's wrong with the airplane could be
on fire
and so we turned and put W in the
compass
and metaphorically I held
W and the compass for nine bloody days
and looked up without turning around
and there was Edwards Air Force Base
ahead of us
I guess the world is round it's so
amazing to me that Norman if you fly a
long ways to get home you got to turn
around and come back
but if you just keep going in the same
direction and you get home
you know it's still it's still strange
you know I guess maybe the world is
round but I know one thing it's a bloody
long ways around the world the world is
25 000 miles at the equator
or just under that
uh the Voyager actually flew 26
358 statute miles unrefueled
we got home with one half of one percent
of our takeoff fuel
so we just barely made it back
but that morning it was beautiful in the
LA Basin at the High Desert tens of
thousands of people came out
and uh
cars were lined up all the way back into
Lancaster
and a lot of people
and somebody says hey dick if you orbit
for 20 minutes more you'll have an even
nine days and I always thought well that
would sound better
and so we orbited around and flew over
the crowd and uh
said things like hey dick what time is
it I says well
it's Miller time you want to go around
once that was the bear at the time
another one says
uh dick what are you going to do now I
says I'm going to Disneyland
and Eisner was the head of Disney
at the time and his wife said that that
was the first time that that thing had
ever been said in public
and then I said after that knowing that
that I invented that or whatever that I
guess Joe Namath or some football player
that won the Super Bowl and he says what
are you going to do now Joe or whatever
his name was well I'm going to
Disneyland well they probably paid him
fifty thousand dollars to do that didn't
pay me anything
but uh
but that day I went out and we put the
landing gear down
and it was going to land in the dry lake
I mean we were so enlightened I could
have landed on my briefcase but it was
going to land at Edwards Air Force Base
and the famous mirac dry lake
so we came around and nothing I was
worried about is on the dry lake there's
no depth perception and I had basically
been awake for nine days I sat in the
seat for three three nights four days
three nights going into the fourth night
it says even dick you can't do this
you've got to get some sleep but I
couldn't put her in the seat because
when we're heavy
if the autopilot kicked off the airplane
would self-destruct in 15 seconds and I
couldn't get to the controls
so we had to wait till we burned off
enough fuel that it would dampen dampen
itself out
so he came around and touched down
a good buddy Mike Melville he counted it
down to five to four three one touchdown
on Aviation salad ground you know where
Chuck Yeager and Scott Crossfield chase
the demons in the sky and what an honor
to be able to land in that place and in
tax taxied up to the crowd
and shut off those engines that had run
for solid for nine days
and I looked around at everybody
and I sat my head but head back a little
bit and I closed my eyes
and it felt every bit as good as I had
imagined it for the last five and a half
years
[Applause]
an airplane hangs in the National Air
and Space Museum
in the mall
well I think they're doing some
renovation they had hung there
you know it's a tribute to a couple of
things to the freedom that we have in
our country
and also that if you can like Mom says
if he can dream it you can do it and the
only way to fail is if you quit and
manage the motivation and in the book
there when uh
President Reagan and Nancy presented to
us the citizens medal
at a just a couple days after the flight
there in Crystal City in Los Angeles
there was some speeches given you know
Bert and I said something and Gina said
something and the president said
something but we got to meet them and
get acquainted with them about who they
were and when we first met in the ante
room before we went on stage to accept
the medals
we started talking
and we were nervous we're going to meet
the president see and as we sit there
and started to talk a little bit
where we were we reversed positions
subconsciously and I realized they're as
nervous as we were
and we got invited to Washington and had
dinner a couple of times in a state
dinner sitting at the same table with
Ronald Reagan but what an honor that was
and his
every bit and in the book it it I found
the transcripts of the words that we're
saying and I read them today it says
I said that extemporaneously
but it turned out really well especially
it's all done because like we talked
during that presentation with the with
the president about freedom
how precious that is
well no doubt about that
um and and the book definitely spells
that out and um
just the the whole story is incredible
your story is incredible
um I want to close out with uh with
something that you write in the book
somebody writing the book about your
your best friend Howard K Williams
as we talked about earlier you call
Howie again he was shot down in Vietnam
it was there was a lot of unknowns about
what had actually happened to him you
had that mystery phone call
and uh
it wasn't until 1992 when his remains
were recovered uh by the pow Mia
resolution task force
and as you mentioned earlier you you
attended the service
and you wrote about that in the book
you say um
how is Howie's military funeral at
Arlington National Cemetery was an
impressive ceremony with full military
honors befitting a Fallen Hero
the pow Mia name bracelets worn by his
friends and family were ceremoniously
added to the Grave
as I turned to leave the grave site I
saw Howard's son
he was only four or five when I had last
seen him at Luke but at this moment I
couldn't believe my eyes
he was the spitting image of his father
my buddy would have been so proud of his
boy
future visits to Washington DC would
always find me
at the Vietnam War Memorial
that's symbolic black granite wall
contains more than 58 000 names of
fellow Warriors killed and missing in
action
I run my fingers over the name of one of
America's Best
and one of my very best friends Howard K
Williams
each time I stand before his engraved
name I swear I see his reflection
smiling back at me from within the dark
Granite surface
I continue to miss him
and for all these years I have wondered
what really happened
I recall the camaraderie and fellowship
of the fledgling fighter pilots off to
test their skills in Mankind's epitome
of human competition deadly combat
and I thank them especially Howie
for their sacrifice
that allows me to live a full life
so sir
thank you
um thanks to you and all your comrades
uh that served and sacrificed for our
freedom
well thank you look at it as a there's a
fellow Warrior
they're just one thing there's an
individual his name is Jeremiah Denton
and he spent many years as a prisoner
War
of the North Vietnamese
and when they picked him up and he got
off the airplane at Clark Air Force Base
After enduring all that
they asked him there was microphone set
up and if he wanted to say a few words
and he gets off the airplane he looks
around for his first
two or three steps
on Free Soil
he walked up to the microphone and he
said something to me so profound
that it epitomizes
fellow Warriors
and and I'm going to say it but my I'm
going to choke up because I can't
I try to imagine what he had gone
through and the words that he spoke that
morning at Clark
and what he said was
I consider it an honor to have had the
privilege
of serving my country
under difficult circumstances
and I think
God as long as there's that kind of
people
that look back on that whole thing as an
honor to serve his country
and I think as long as there are those
people
our flag will still be free
yes sir
yes sir indeed
and I don't think I can say anything
else beyond that other than thank you
thank you junko it's an honor to be here
and with that
Dick Rutan has left the building also
Dave Burke left the building he's
escorting
he's asked Gordon Dick Rutan back to the
hotel they're probably gonna sit and
talk about
uh flying for a while
so
just incredible story obviously
um read the book
get the book the next five minutes it's
called
it's just incredible to be able to sit
here with a guy like that and hear these
stories just rolling in
to North Vietnam tracers everywhere
locking blocking eyes with those
enemy Fighters trying to kill you and
doing that day after day after day after
day after day after day after day
that's the American fighting spirit so
thanks for listening if you want to
support the podcast go to jockoffuel.com
we make the best cleanest most effective
supplements to put inside your body
so go to jockoffool.com and get some of
that if you have a Wawa near you you
have a vitamin shop military
commissaries Hannaford's Dash stores in
Maryland wake Fern ShopRite Circle K HEB
of course down in Tejas Murphy's down
the southeast and Meyer Meyer in the
midwest get go get Jocko fuel it's a
great way to support the podcast what
we're doing here
and it's a great way to support yourself
don't forget about originusa.com go get
your hunt gear Jiu Jitsu gear
rash guards geese t-shirts boots Delta
jeans
get yourself some Delta genes from
originusa.com
the you can also get stuff from Jocko's
store
Jocko store.com got all kinds of stuff
to get I guess
get a bunch get yourself a bunch of cool
stuff from jakastore.com
and uh you guys know the rest man
subscribe to the podcast check out Jocko
underground.com we got the YouTube
channel we got psychological warfare a
bunch of books again the book the
important book for today is the next
five minutes
uh by Dick Rutan just an awesome book an
awesome read you know about Jocko
publishing we got a bunch of books
only cry for the living by Holly McKay
I've written a bunch of books you can
check those out as well
um kids books
way the warrior kid one two and three
get some of that Echelon front look
these principles that we talk about
about combat they also apply to Everyday
Life to business and we talk about those
and we teach those at Echelon front
echelonfront.com for details come to one
of our Live Events so that these lessons
get shared they get passed on we also
have the online Training Academy at
extreme ownership.com where you can
learn this stuff
all mine don't you don't need to go
somewhere to get this information
and also if you want to help service
members
active and retired
you want to help their families you want
to help gold star families check out
Markley's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organization and if you want to
donate or do you want to get involved go
to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
don't forget about heroes and horses.org
you got Micah up in the wilderness
helping people find themselves
yep Dave Burks on Twitter he's on the
gram he's on Facebook at Dave R Burke
I'm there to add Jocko willink and
thanks once again to Dick Rutan for
joining us
for sharing his lessons learned sharing
these incredible experiences and thanks
to him
and to all the other military aviators
that rule the sky and give us dominance
and they pay a heavy price for it
and thanks to the rest of our military
personnel who also pay the price every
day to keep us safe and protect our way
of life in this great nation and the
same goes to the police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all First Responders
you all keep us safe here at home and we
thank you for that and to everyone else
out there today you heard what Dick
Rutan said
and he talks about in the book he talks
about
what his mother would tell him and at
one point in the book we didn't cover
today he talks about sometimes when he
was facing an a seemingly insurmountable
problem or challenge he would run he
would go and run to clear his mind he'd
do it for physical fitness but he did it
to clear his mind to gain perspective
and sometimes he says in the book
you would
chant that Cadence that he spoke of that
he learned from his mom
which is you only fail if you quit
and that is the truth
so
go out there
don't quit and keep getting after it
and until next time this is Jocko
out